bonjour à toutes et à tous mes chers
collègues je suis ravie de vous
retrouver après des vacances qui
j'espère auront été reposantes et nous
nous retrouvons ce matin pour entendre
monsieur Edouard Geffray directeur
général de l'enseignement scolaire
Monsieur le Directeur général je vous
remercie de vous être rendu disponible
et comme je vous le disais en aparté
c'est presque désormais une tradition
que nos travaux démarrent par une série
d'audition sur le thème de la rentrée
scolaire et plus largement sur les
enjeux les plus importants pour nos
écoles collèges et lycée nous allons
ainsi ainsi entendre cet après-midi les
représentants des syndicats de
l'enseignement public du premier et du
second degré
après la rentrée de l'année dernière
marquée par un manque important
d'enseignant cette rentrée la première
pour notre nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
fait suite à l'apparition pendant l'été
d'un grand nombre de textes
réglementaires précisant notamment
l'organisation du pacte enseignant sur
lequel je ne doute pas Monsieur le
Directeur Général que vous serez
interrogé par nos collègues pour ma part
j'ai également quelques questions la
rentrée scolaire s'est déroulée il y a
trois semaines et nous avons entendu à
la fois les propos du ministre disant
qu'elle s'était globalement bien passées
et ceux des syndicats évoquant des
difficultés concrètes qu'en est-il selon
vous par rapport à la rentrée 2022 2023
a-t-on à ce jour un bilan chiffré et
objectif de la rentrée faisant notamment
état du nombre de postes non pourvu
cette question des effectifs est
d'autant plus importante que certains
établissements et niveau de classe
bénéficient de plafonnement des
effectifs je pense à l'éducation
prioritaire et à l'éducation prioritaire
renforcée le dédoublement des classes
est-il désormais satisfait à 100% , y
compris dans les collectivités
territoires ultramarins tels que Mayotte
la Guyane qui souffrent en plus du
manque d'enseignants de problèmes de
bâties scolaire
cette question du bâti me conduit à vous
interroger sur le projet de
généralisation du service national
universel et c'est nu sur le temps
scolaire en effet un certain nombre
d'établissements publics locaux
d'enseignement notamment ce disposant
d'un
utilisé pour la réalisation du séjour de
cohésion
quels seront les modalités d'accueil des
élèves dans les classes engagées sur le
temps scolaire à partir de quand les
premiers séjours d'une classe entière
pourront-ils avoir lieu et seront-ils
réalisés lors du premier semestre 2024
et 2024 est également l'année de la
promotion de l'activité physique et
sportive comme grande cause nationale
quels sont les projets mis en place par
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse pour accompagner cette
promotion et les dispositifs mis en
place des dernières années et je pense
notamment aux 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidienne plus souvent
appelée APQ en primaire mais surtout les
deux heures de sport en plus au collège
font l'objet d'un bilan en demi-teinte
depuis octobre 2022 combien de collèges
se sont-ils portés volontaires étant
combien de départements l'objectif des
700 collèges publics et privés annoncés
par la ministre des Sports dans une
instruction du mois d'avril de 2023 vous
semble-t-il atteignable comment le
ministère de l'éducation est celui des
sports travaille-t-il à le rendre plus
vite plus efficace
donc vous voyez monsieur le directeur
général un certain nombre de questions
et je sais que mes collègues vous en
poseront encore beaucoup d'autres mais
en attendant je vais vous laisser la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
afin que vous puissiez nous faire ce
bilan de rentrée
merci beaucoup la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vous remercie
de bien vouloir nous additionner
aujourd'hui autour donc de cette rentrée
scolaire alors de je confirme
effectivement que en tout cas
techniquement cette rentrée scolaire
c'est bien passée comme vous le savez
nous avions beaucoup moins de
difficultés notamment en termes RH c'est
à dire que la situation est parfaitement
rétablie mais la situation était
clairement été clairement moins tendue
et le ministre est l'occasion de
rappeler il y a quelques jours que la
DGH donc nous indiquer qu'on était à peu
près à 200 postes aujourd'hui non pourvu
donc ça fait que concrètement cette
rentrée c'est entre guillemets mieux
passer que la précédente avec moins de
tension en termes en termes RH ce qui
veut pas dire bien sûr que c'est parfait
mais ce qui signifie que on est sur une
trajectoire de rétablissement qui est on
va dire
à suivre mais qui est quand même
globalement meilleur
alors peut-être en cette rentrée et du
coup à la fois pour répondre à votre
question et vous dresser un petit
panorama
on a en fait trois axes et donc sur ces
trois axes un certain nombre de mesures
nouvelles ou de chantier que vous
connaissez bien sûr mais sur lesquels je
voudrais revenir quelques instants le
premier chantier constant et qui est
vraiment évidemment essentiel c'est
l'élévation du niveau général et
notamment dans ce qu'on appelle souvent
les savoirs fondamentaux lire et écrire
compter de ce point de vue là comme nous
avons l'occasion de nous voir
régulièrement je voudrais simplement me
permettre de faire un petit retour
arrière sur deux éléments importants
donc vous savez qu'on a des émulations
chaque année nationale
cpmcpce1 6e et puis des tests de
positionnement 30 secondes et puis nous
avons également j'allais dire un cycle
d'évaluation d'évaluation pardon
internationale
or depuis maintenant 18 mois nous avons
d'abord une enquête qui s'appelle
enquête cèdre qui est une enquête sur
les mathématiques et tout l'enquête
Pearl ce qui est la première enquête
internationale dont nous avions le
résultat depuis que nous ont mis en
place un stand de mesure
et ces deux enquêtes comme les
évaluations de 6e
témoignent d'une progression
du niveau des élèves français ce qui au
niveau international n'est pas arrivé
depuis 25 ans
que vous le savez qu'on avait qu'on
était structurellement chaque année on
perdait des points on perd des points
dans l'absolu on perdait des rangs par
rapport aux autres pays une enquête
Pearl montre un phénomène qui est inédit
et donc qui pour nous est évidemment
trading d'intérêt c'est que non
seulement la France n'a pas baissé entre
2016 et 2021 date à laquelle l'enquête
Pearl a été effectuée mais les résultats
de ces élèves ont même progressé en
nombre de points nets et elle est le
seul pays d'Europe dont le résultat ont
progressé
alors bien sûr on peut expliquer la
baisse d'ensemble des autres pays par le
covid la fermeture des classes on a
moins fermé que les autres etc etc enfin
logiquement étant donné qu'on a quand
même fermé comme tout le monde malgré
tout une partie du temps moins que les
autres mais un peu quand même on aurait
pu s'attendre un tassement de nos
résultats alors là non seulement on n'a
pas de tassement il y en a même eu une
progression donc on a aujourd'hui des
indices qui sont des indices que je
qualifierais de d'intéressant qui sont
évidemment à suivre on aura les
résultats de pizza on aura d'autres
résultats mais qui quand même
globalement témoigne une forme de
consolidation du niveau progressive et
c'est une consolidation qu'on observe
nous au niveau de nos évaluations
nationales évaluation commerciale qui
comme vous le savez c'est un des
éléments de cette rentrée vont être
étendues puisque cette année nous avons
en août des évaluations en CM1 et en
quatrième pourquoi en CM1 en 4e tout
simplement parce que entre le CE1 et la
sixième
on constate qu'il y a un certain nombre
de d'éléments qui notamment en termes de
fluence qui devrait en principe servir
par une amélioration
et dont on pense qu'en fait il s'étiole
au fur et à mesure des années et donc ça
nous permet d'avoir une photographie à
l'entrée en cycle 3 et pourquoi en 4e
tout simplement pour la même raison
c'est-à-dire qu'entre la 6e et le
diplination du brevet aujourd'hui entre
guillemets on ne sait pas au niveau
national comme au niveau d'une classe en
positionnement national véritablement ce
qu'il se passe mais on observe qu'il y a
une forme de de pérennité parfois de la
difficulté ou de pérenniser la réussite
d'ailleurs qu'on a besoin de mieux
analyser une mieux expliqué pour pouvoir
agir à l'échelle de la classe
deuxième élément donc parallèlement à
celui-ci ça c'est si je puis dire
l'outil de mesure qui est donc pour la
première fois depuis longtemps nous
donne des raisons de de sourire en tout
cas
deuxième élément c'est bien sûr l'action
sur les pratiques pédagogiques
elles-mêmes
donc vous savez qu'on a un plan de
formation depuis années qui s'appelle le
plan français le plan mathématique
ce plan se poursuit 54% des professeurs
des écoles en ont d'ores et déjà
bénéficier
et ce qui est intéressant là aussi c'est
que nous commençons à avoir un certain
nombre à avoir un stand d'éléments de
retour qui montre un effet sur le niveau
effectif des élèves je me balance tes
guerres de faire un zoom sur le
département de Mayotte nous avons à
Mayotte comme vous le savez mieux que
moi ensemble de difficultés sociales
évidemment qui sont extrêmement
préoccupantes et il se trouve que
c'était un appartement dont les élèves
étaient enfin dans avec des résultats
qui étaient très en deçà de la moyenne
nationale on a fait un plan de formation
pour les professionnels écoles en CP en
CE1 notamment
il y a deux ans les élèves à mi-cp 30%
des élèves de Mute était entrés dans la
lecture à mi CP ils étaient plus de 50%
en février 2023 et en CE1 on atteignait
pas les 50% à l'entraînement ils étaient
à 70% cette année donc ça veut dire que
quand on articule
les pratiques pédagogiques et un certain
nombre d'éléments de conditions
d'apprentissage on arrive objectivement
à changer assez rapidement puisque le
plan de formation en l'occurrence c'est
lui il y a moins de 18 mois assez
rapidement
les résultats de nos élèves le troisième
élément toujours sur cette partie
pédagogique
c'est bien sûr instant de mesures de
trajectoire globale donc
notamment autour de des serres
fondamentaux donc on y avoir si vous
voulez mais évidemment quand vous voulez
mais on agit en fait sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne le plan maternelle puisqu'on
sait que c'est un maternelle que ce nous
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses en termes
d'apprentissage notamment en termes
d'apprentissage de la diversité du
vocabulaire de phonologie et puis de
découverte des nombres donc il y a un
plan maternel spécifique qui a été lancé
et les plantes et français vont avoir
une déclinaison spéciale maternelle nous
poursuivons donc le travail sur les
cycles 2 et cycles 3 notamment autour de
l'écriture le ministre est l'occasion
d'ailleurs de s'exprimer récemment sur
l'ambition qu'on avait à la matière
la nouvelle sixième schéma en place
actuellement et là aussi comme vous le
savez l'objectif c'est de corriger des
éventuelles
lacunes ou fragilité des élèves en leur
proposant une heure par semaine de
soutien dédié sur les compétences pour
lesquelles ils sont en fragilité en
mathématiques ou en français et puis en
rendant obligatoire devoir faire donc
l'ensemble de ces éléments participent
d'une congélation des serveurs
fondamentaux et puis pour la suite du
parcours si je poursuis la suite du
parcours de l'élève vous avez également
comme vous le savez en cette rentrée un
certain nombre d'évolutions importantes
au collège donc ce qu'on appelle en
cycle 4 cinquième quatrième troisième la
mise en place dans tous les
établissements de ce qu'on appelle la
découverte des métiers
puisqu'on sait bien qu'au bout d'un
moment ce qui se joue ce qui se joue
beaucoup dans le premier degré c'est la
messe de la fondamentaux ce qui se joue
beaucoup au collège c'est
l'élargissement des ambitions donc
découverte des métiers cinquième et
quatrième troisième pour faire en sorte
que nous élèves tout simplement
regarde plus loin et plus largement les
perspectives qui leur sont ouvertes et
puis au niveau du lycée
mise en place des premières mesures de
réforme de la professionnelle avec
notamment la gratification des périodes
de formation en milieu professionnel et
la création bureau d'entreprise plus un
stand de mesure qui trouve à s'appliquer
notamment pour la première fois
l'apparition en seulement optionnel si
vous savez que le paradoxe c'est souvent
qu'on dit que les élèves professionnels
sont moins comment dire sont moins
attirés par les matières d'enseignement
d'enseignement général mais le paradoxe
aussi c'est que ils ont probablement la
scolarité enfin la maquette scolaire la
plus rigide de tous les aides de lycée
et donc on introduit un somme optionnel
pour précisément répondre aussi à leur
goûts à leurs appétences une volonté de
diversification de leur parcours et de
l'autre côté évidemment on voit général
technologique les choses se stabilisent
bien sûr par rapport à la réforme du
lycée
à une exception notable près c'est que
les mathématiques sont réintroduites
pour tous les élèves en règle générale
en classe de première de manière à ce
que tous les élèves de France fassent
des mathématiques au moins jusqu'à la
fin de la classe de Première donc ça
c'est sur la partie peut-être
pédagogique avec les principales
nouveautés de cette rentrée sur la
partie condition d'apprentissage
maintenant puisque je disais tout à
l'heure que les deux étaient évidemment
les deux jambes de la réussite des
élèves
donc là dessus vous savez qu’un nombre
de d'éléments qui sont évidemment se
poursuivent vous m'avez interrogé
d'ailleurs sur les dédoublements donc
les doublement sont déjà réalisés à 100%
pour les CP les CE1 nous un objectif qui
est de 84%
cette année sur les grandes sections
l'idée grande sections en délégation
prioritaire l'année prochaine quant au
plafonnement à 24 qui lui est universel
des grandes sections des CP et des CE1
il est bien achevé et donc en cette
rentrée nous avons des des classes qui
sont à moins de 24 ce qui évidemment
participent des conditions de
d'apprentissage renforcés des élèves
au-delà de cela tout l'enjeu en fait
c'est de penser un comment dire un
soutien scolaire adapté pour les élèves
qui sont en difficulté notamment sur
soit pendant l'année soit sur des temps
dont on sait qu'ils sont des temps qui
peuvent porter préjudice à leur niveau
d'apprentissage c'est connu et des
études qui ont été faites que vous
connaissez aussi deux mois de vacances
d'été
en éducation prioritaire et qui va là un
mois de perte d'apprentissage autrement
dit un enfant en l'éducation
propriétaire statistiquement c'est des
statistiques bien sûr c'est pas une
science exacte et c'est pas des rapports
pas besoin d'individus bien évidemment
mais statistiquement ça veut dire qu'un
enfant quand il fait sa rentrée en
obligation prêteur le 1er septembre il a
le niveau qu'il avait non pas le 4
juillet mais le premier juin
et donc l'un des enjeux pour nous
notamment le cadre du Pacte enseignant
c'est de développer les stages de
réussite et de faire en sorte
précisément que soit en début d'été soit
en fin d'été et ces éléments ou sur
petites vacances qui permettent
finalement non seulement une pas perdre
mais même éventuellement de récupérer
s'il avait certaines points de fragilité
à travailler et donc c'est évidemment ce
que nous allons fortement développé
cette année en parallèle autrement dit
conditions d'apprentissage améliorées si
je puis dire dans le quotidien de la
classe et puis soutien renforcé pour les
effets qui en ont besoin à la fois donc
sur temps sur ces temps de vacances on
va dire
petite vacances ou proche de rentrer ou
de ou de fin de l'année et puis aussi
dans l'année puisque dans le cadre du
Pacte d'enseignant également nous
mettons en place des dispositifs de
soutien dans le premier degré
qui permettent aux élèves là encore de
bénéficier d'un certain nombre de
d'heures de soutien tout au long de
l'année troisième élément et après je me
tais pour tenir les 15 minutes mais
comme ça ça me permettra de brosser le
portrait très très général et pardon
mettre aussi général mais il y a
beaucoup de dimensions c'est bien sûr la
dimension de protection et
d'émancipation qui est évidemment qui
marque évidemment cette rentrée alors
bien sûr quand on parle de protection on
pense immédiatement au drame qui se sont
passés
ces derniers jours et ces derniers mois
en termes de harcèlement et donc au
combat contre le harcèlement qui est
dans le ministre a fait une priorité
absolue et dont le gouvernement et je
crois l'ensemble de la nation font une
priorité absolue pour vraiment réduire
ce fléau qui est insupportable donc
j'imagine qu'il y aura peut-être des
questions et puis il y a bien sûr aussi
cette dimension d'une école qui qui est
mon site alors vous avez cité tout à
l'heure le sport je vous confirme que en
cette rentrée
nous avons fixé pour objectif que bien
sûr les 30 minutes quotidiennes soit
pratiqués dans 100% des écoles
on sait que c'était pas forcément le cas
absolument partout et donc là cette
année on a remis si je puis dire
l'ouvrage sur le métier pour faire en
sorte que cette activité physique
quotidienne soit parce qu'il y a 100%
des écoles avec d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'éléments institutifs de type
kit de matériel etc qui seront tous
enfin dans la diffusion sera achevée en
fin d'année civile donc fin décembre au
plus tard tout début 2024 et puis il y a
effectivement cette dimension aussi de
pratique sportive au collège avec les
deux heures de sport en plus pour les
collégiens qui le souhaitent et je vous
confirme que nous avons effectivement
plus de 700 c'est 7004 ou 706 je crois
collège qui se sont engagés dans cette
démarche et que nous sommes actuellement
en train accompagnés j'étais pas plutôt
la semaine dernière en visioconférence
avec l'ensemble des 700 proviseurs
principaux pardon 700 principaux pour
partager avec eux un certain nombre
d'éléments de nature à les faire à leur
permettre de mettre en place les
dispositifs c'est également cette école
qui est mon site celle qui ouvre à
l'altérité à l'esthétique et donc qui
garantit le 100% acé avec l'extension de
la part collective du Pass Culture au
sixième au 5e ce qui signifie que tout
élève de la sixième jusqu'à la terminale
bénéficie désormais en fait d'une prise
en charge à hauteur de 25 euros au
collège et puis ensuite 30 puis 20 euros
lycée de ces activités d'éducation
agriculturelles qui les amené dont il
aime bien bénéficier avec avec ses
professeurs pour vous donner une petite
idée c'est un dispositif qui est donc
très récent et la 18 mois alors il est
apparu en plein contexte sanitaire
de crise covid etc donc à un moment où
on prend pas beaucoup de sorties
scolaires donc les 6 premiers mois ne
l'ont pas empêché de décoller mais à peu
près 40% des établissement sur les
thésant pareil pour sa première année
scolaire pleine 92% des établissements
ont utilisé la parcotille du bascule et
donc évidemment on s'attend à cette
rentrée à
100% d'usage puisque on était vraiment
sur une sur une queue de comète qui va
désormais être définitivement accompli
et puis le dernier point est comme ça
j'aurai tenu dans les 15 minutes en une
minute bien sûr c'est aussi sur cette
école qui émancipe et qui si je puis
dire retrouve de l'oxygène
c'est cette question
du CNR sous lequel on se rappelle aussi
amené à échanger donc le Conseil ça
refondation éducation qui constitue une
vraie une vraie évolution culturelle
puisqu'elle consiste à partir des
projets des équipes et elle est soutenir
et financer pour leur permettre
d'atteindre leur d'atteindre les
objectifs qu'elles se sont fixés
en partant des besoins réellement
constatés et qu'elle même observe de
leurs élèves et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que en un an on a à peu près 19000
écoles établissements qui ont manifesté
leur intérêt 8500 qui ont déposé un
projet
3300 d'ores et déjà dont le projet a été
validé financé et qui est donc en cette
rentrée mis en oeuvre dans les écoles et
ces 3300 projets donc qui sont qui ont
étéveillés financés qui donc sont en
train de se mettre en oeuvre dans dans
ces écoles établissements pour vous
donner un de grandeur il concerne dans
un déjà plus d'un million d'élèves
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on a plus
d'un million d'élèves en France qui sont
dans une école ou un établissement qui
met en place un projet CNR voilà pardon
de ce de cette fresque à la fois trop
longue et a trop gros coup de pinceaux
mais ça permet de couvrir à peu près
l'ensemble des éléments de cette rentrée
merci beaucoup justement pour d'avoir
brossé
dans cette cette rentrée mais ça va
permettre à mes collègues de vous poser
des questions maintenant de façon certes
sûrement plus précise dans un certain
nombre de sujets et nous allons
commencer avec les orateurs de groupe
pour 2 minutes avec pour Renaissance
karl Olive
mes chers collègues cher Monsieur le
Directeur général il ne voulait pas
mourir mais il n'en pouvait plus de
souffrir je veux vous parler ici de
Nicolas que nous connaissions bien à
Poissy lui et sa famille il avait 15 ans
j'aurais aimé partager les très bons
résultats cette année encore des élèves
du lycée professionnel Adrienne Bolland
un établissement de 750 élèves à
l'enseignement reconnu un savoir-faire
exemplaire dans les métiers d'art du
bois et de la mode mais c'est une
immense peine et une colère noire qui
nous surmerge comme un tsunami et je le
dis avec beaucoup d'émotions
ce poison du harcèlement qui a consumé
ce jeune adolescent jusqu'à son
impensable geste de désespoir la
pendaison
ce harcèlement qui saute aux yeux mais
qu'on ne veut pas voir
déclinaison en trois points une
altercation avec les harceleurs le 30
septembre dernier dans la cour à l'heure
du déjeuner t'es moche tu es nul je vais
baiser ta mère sous les yeux d'un
enseignant qui dira ne rien pouvoir
faire car les faits se sont déroulés à
la pause méridienne
une rencontre ensuite des parents avec
le proviseur pour crier à l'aide réponse
de l'intéressé je vous ai fait part de
mon interrogation d'être sollicité en
mars pour une situation dont vous avez
connaissance supposément depuis
septembre il n'y a pas plus aveugle que
celui qui ne veut pas voir
le cauchemar enfin celui du rectorat qui
est dans une missive sans âme nous
plonge dans un dégoût sans nom dans
l'intérêt de votre enfant et par souci
d'exemplarité à son égard je vous
enjoins d'adopter une attitude
constructive menace à la clé les
victimes deviennent coupables nous avons
tous notre part de responsabilité dans
cette chaîne d'éducation où chaque
maillon façonne le bien-être et le bien
vivre de nos futurs générations mais
combien de temps encore Monsieur le
Directeur l'éducation nationale
va-t-elle se draper dans des postures de
cécité et de surdité comment allez-vous
casser cette Homer plat contagieuse ou
les compromis entre adultes prennent le
pas sur la souffrance des enfants et des
familles alors permettez-moi cette
suggestion et si vous commenciez par
harceler les harceleur harceler
administrativement les harceleurs dès la
première heure comme les harceleurs
harcèle psychologiquement et
physiquement leur proie
ils sont 800 000 à 1 million chaque
année être victime de ce fléau il
s'appelait Lucas Lindsay et Nicolas il
ne méritait pas ça
merci monsieur le député pour le
rassemblement national Roger judo merci
Madame Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
Général évidemment nous associons
indignation que suscite le harcèlement
dans notre dans notre école mais je
voulais me dire que en général vous
interrogez enfin plutôt
intervenir sur le Conseil national de la
refondation de l'école que vous appelez
révolution copernicienne enfin plutôt de
président de la République appelle
révolution copernicienne école du futur
notre école faisant là ensemble avec une
dotation de 500 millions d'euros sur la
législature et reposant évidemment sur
volontariat quelles sont les réalités de
ce
CNR école ce sont comme vous le disiez
3300 projets financés sauf qu'il y a
55000 unités éducatives et que ça fait
donc à peine 5% ou 6% des unités
éducatives qui ont adhéré à ce projet
ensuite vous parlez de volontariat or
dans une visioconférence récente vous
avez en juin
aux inspecteurs de
d'accélérer le processus parce que ça ne
démarre pas donc c'est quand même du
pilotage assez directif ensuite il n'y a
aucun cadrage c'est-à-dire que ces
projets sont des projets à effet
d'aubaine on y trouve de tout on y
trouve le la rénovation du mobilier la
chatte collection la végétalisation de
la cour etc donc ceci n'a franchement
aucun sens et aucun rapport n'est ce pas
avec l'action éducatrice et le
renforcement que vous le souhaitiez de
la maîtrise des fondamentaux ce qui est
embêtant c'est que les projets
établissements existent depuis 85 sont
obligatoires depuis 89 qui ne sont ni
pilotés ni évalués par la DGS ils sont
remplacés par ce machin qui est le
centre Conseil national de la
refondation d'école notre point de vue
c'est que il s'agit d'un démontage pur
et simple du système éducatif avez-vous
pensé monsieur directeur général à ce
que l'on pourrait faire avec 500
millions d'euros en termes de d'achets
ça pour le soutien scolaire ça aurait
été beaucoup plus intéressant et pour
rehausser le niveau de nos enfants à
l'antré 6e dans 50% ne savent pas lire
de manière fluide donc
de conseil national était concernational
pour citer les versions de rien en 2027
nous renationaliserons l'éducation
nationale afin qu'elle soit en mesure de
faire face aux défis que la nation devra
affronter demain je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député pour elle est finie
bonjour à toutes et à tous madame la
Présidente Monsieur directeur chers
collègues les annonces du ministère se
sont multipliées depuis la fin de l'été
entre celle qui promettait la présence
d'un enseignant devant chaque classe et
celle qui prévoyait une hausse des
salaires de tous les enseignants afin
que leur paix soit enfin revalorisé
force et de constater que nous n'avons
pas eu la même rentrée que Monsieur le
Ministre puisque d'abord les hausses de
salaire promise n'ont pas eu lieu et les
salaires des enseignants ne dépassent
même pas l'inflation des deux dernières
années aussi il y a deux semaines il
manquait en moyenne un enseignant dans
50% des collèges et lycées de France
Monsieur le Directeur vous servez l'État
et nous vous en sommes reconnaissants
les mots que j'emploie aujourd'hui n'ont
pour objectif
de vous mettre personnellement en cause
bien au contraire pour autant cette 1900
postes avait été supprimé dans les
collèges et lycées publics entre 2017 et
2022 et les suppressions des 1117
enseignants du premier degré et de 480
du second degré ont été introduites et
votées dans la loi de finance de 2023
pourtant en parallèle sur les 40
dernières années le nombre d'enfants en
âge d'être scolarisés et rester
globalement stable dans l'ouvrage
enfance de classe de bernard Lahire qui
fustigeait les régressions en matière de
scolarisation et de réduction de poste
et déclaré à cet égard qu'à chaque recul
de l'État dans tous les domaines
concernant la famille dont la scolarité
fait partie ce sont des inégalités qui
se creusent entre les classes sociales
et des horizons qui se renferment
referme pardon le paradoxe entre les
annonces des enseignants devant chaque
classe les suppressions massives de
poste sans parler les suppressions de
classe et les discours de Monsieur Attal
se disant révoltés par un système
éducatif qui accroît les inégalités
m'amène à vous poser la question
suivante selon vous comment pouvons-nous
solutionner réellement les manques
d'effectifs et de moyens dans
l'éducation nationale à l'approche du
projet de loi de finances pour l'année
2024 plus précisément quels sont les
hausses nécessaires à même de mettre fin
au fiasco de chaque rentrée scolaire et
d'assurer une égalité réelle dans
l'accès à l'éducation
merci monsieur le député pour les
républicains Annie genvar merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
général le truc commission est heureuse
de vous recevoir aujourd'hui votre
fonction présentée sur le site du
ministère en dit l'importance votre
direction est en effet chargée
d'élaborer la politique éducative et
pédagogique et d'assurer la mise en
œuvre la mise en œuvre des programmes et
des formations continues en cette
période de rentrée scolaire votre
présence devant nous a du sens en
attendant celle de monsieur le ministre
je voudrais vous rappeler les quatre
priorités des républicains en matière
d'éducation tout d'abord réaffirmer la
mission première de l'éducation
nationale à savoir l'enseignement des
savoirs fondamentaux à l'école primaire
et l'enseignement de connaissances
disciplinaire solide dans le secondaire
restaurer l'autorité la place des
professeurs dans le système éducatif
garantir l'égalité des chances à tous
les élèves par la capacité à réussir
grâce à une réponse pédagogique adaptée
non pas seulement à travers le le prisme
social et enfin avoir une vraie gestion
des ressources humaines qui est
dramatiquement absente dans ce ministère
je veux Monsieur le Directeur Général
vous interrogez sur la question des
savoirs fondamentaux le ministre parle
d'un choc des savoirs comme les
Allemands ont pu parler en son temps
d'un choc pizza après avoir connu de
très mauvais classement à ces
évaluations internationales c'est la
même où nous obtenons de médiocres
résultats qui humilient une école qui
faisait autrefois notre fierté et
surtout qui altère la confiance que les
Français ont dans leur école
l'instauration d'une sixième
hebdomadaire de soutien et
d'approfondissement en maths et en
français ne suffira pas j'en suis
convaincu à consolider les
apprentissages nécessaires au collège je
rappelle Monsieur le Directeur Général
s'il en était besoin qu'un tiers des
élèves qui arrivent en sixième ne
maîtrise pas la lecture c'est quand même
une situation absolument dramatique et
je pense qu'elle ne peut pas être passée
sous silence ma question est donc la
suivante alors que la France consacre
plus de temps que ses voisins européens
l'apprentissage des savoirs fondamentaux
les élèves les résultats de nos élèves
sont médiocres voilà voire alarmants
notamment en mathématiques cela
interroge donc les méthodes
d'enseignement quelle mesure concrètes
entendez-vous donner à ce choc des
savoirs je tiens à vous préciser que les
parlementaires y apporteront leur
contribution puisque Fabrice le
vigoureux et moi allons conduire une
mission apprentissage de la ligne merci
Madame la député pour les démocrates
Philippe Bertin
c'est bon vas-y vas-y merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur Général
la chute fulgurante du niveau
scientifique des élèves se confirme le
dernier numéro de la recherche relève
l'étendue des enjeux et des difficultés
d'un enseignement des sciences et des
mathématiques de l'école primaire pour
exemple les élèves français en fin de
CM1 figurent désormais en avoir dernière
position des pays de l'OCDE juste devant
le Chili dans le cadre de mon rapport
pour le budget de la recherche de l'an
dernier dans la thématique portait sur
la culture scientifique j'avais
auditionné la Direction Générale de
l'Enseignement scolaire sur le contenu
et la rédaction scientifique des manuels
scolaires et même des programmes
fort cette constater que suite aux
réponses émises par la direction et au
Costa fait par un certain nombre de nos
collègues académiciens de nombreux
erreurs scientifiques assez graves
figurent dans les manuels et les
programmes scolaires support qui servent
pourtant aux enseignants et aux élèves
tout au long de leur scolarité
aussi depuis 2022 pourriez-vous s'il
vous plaît nous indiquer si une
réévaluation du système rédactionnel a
été entreprise si les manuels et les
programmes actuels sont laissés à
disposition du corps enseignant et des
élèves le cas échéant ne pensez-vous pas
que les partis scientifiques des manuels
et programme ne devrait-elle pas être
rédigées supervisé par des scientifiques
ou en tous les cas les maquettes finales
validées par ces derniers je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
les socialistes et apparentés
fatihacohashi oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur général
je souhaiterais vous parler
spécifiquement de quatre sujets qui
résument les inquiétudes formulées par
les parents d'élèves et les équipes
pédagogiques de nos circonscriptions à
cette rentrée premièrement le sujet des
classes surchargées en effet dans le
premier degré les sur effectifs nous
inquiète
cette problématique ne date pas d'hier
et nous pouvons convenir que la baisse
du nombre d'enseignants décidés dans le
précédent projet de loi de finance n'a
rien arrangé au lieu de profiter de la
baisse démographique afin d'alléger les
classes vous avez préféré faire des
économies sur le dos de nos jeunes et je
vais vous donner un exemple au Lycée
professionnel Jean Moulin à
Rosny-sous-Bois les élèves sont 30 par
classe alors qu'il devrait être 22 alors
même que 30 13 500 jeunes n'ont toujours
pas d'affectation à lycée deuxième gros
problème le manque d'enseignants
comme nous pouvions nous y attendre la
promesse du président de la République
d'un enseignant devant chaque classe
n'est pas tenu pardon d'un enseignant
devant chaque élève m'en servir au même
en deux mois la crise profonde du
recrutement des enseignants ne s'est pas
résolu et il manque en moyenne au moins
un enseignant dans 50% des
établissements scolaires
toujours le même exemple Lycée
professionnel Jean Moulin il manquait à
la rentrée et il manque encore
aujourd'hui 11 enseignants
et deux professeurs vont partir à la
retraite au mois d'octobre donc au total
il manquera très enseignants qui a de la
date d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas remplacés
comment un établissement peut-il
fonctionner ainsi troisième souci majeur
le manque
d'accompagnant pour les enfants en
situation de handicap vous le savez un
accompagnement humain est indispensable
et une condition sinequanone pour qu'un
élève en situation de handicap puisse
s'intégrer dans les classes or dans les
piales de ma circonscription il manquait
40% d'Ash pour couvrir la totalité des
notifications MDPH
avec le groupe socialiste nous demandons
depuis plusieurs années l'amélioration
des conditions de travail de ces
personnels qui sont essentiels afin de
rendre le métier plus attractif dernier
problème le pacte le pacte qui n'est pas
une réussite on est bien d'accord les
enseignants ne veulent pas du travailler
plus pour gagner plus qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui comment vont fonctionner les
établissements alors que moins de 30%
des enseignants ont signé le pacte merci
madame la députée pour les horizons et à
parenté Jérémy patrietus merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur général
je vous remercie de venir devant notre
commission quelques semaines après la
rentrée scolaire
député de Lisieux vous me permettrez de
rendre ici hommage aux principales
Stéphane Vittel retrouvé mort dans
l'ensemble de son collège le collège de
la place le 11 août dernier bus Sarre
noire de la République Stéphane Vittel
avait dédié sa vie à ses élèves et à
l'école de la République pour lui comme
pour de nombreux enseignants le métier
de professeur n'était pas un choix de
carrière mais le choix d'une vie une vie
toute entière dévouée à la réussite et à
l'épanouissement des élèves ma première
question vous le comprendrez portera
donc naturellement sur la sécurité de
nos chefs d'établissement et de nos
enseignants comment l'État peut
travailler avec les collectivités
locales pour renforcer la sécurité des
personnels établir une doctrine mettre
des moyens est-il acceptable qu'un
principal se rende seul dans son
établissement au coeur de l'été suite au
signal d'une alarme anti-intrusion
ma deuxième question qui est tout à la
fois une alerte rouge porte sur le
harcèlement scolaire qui pourrit notre
école de la République le ministre a eu
des mots forts mon collègue de Poissy
meurtrit comme tous les Français par la
pendaison d'un élève vient lui aussi
d'avoir des mots graves pour décrire
cette cécité collective
pensez-vous que les rectorats prennent
la mesure de la gravité du harcèlement
et son point de capacité de détecter les
cas de harcèlement et d'y répondre
comment peut-on engager la
responsabilité de ceux qui n'ont pas
voulu ou ne veulent pas voir ce qui se
complaisent à s'aveugler que pensez-vous
en fin de la création d'une cellule
signalement harcèlement scolaire qui
serait directement rattaché à
l'administration centrale car
personnellement je ne suis pas certain
que les rectorats soient toujours en
capacité de lutter efficacement contre
ce fléau pour continuer sur la question
du harcèlement j'aimerais avoir votre
regard sur le cyber-assadmand et sur ce
que peut faire l'état pour contrer cette
violence qui se déroule hors les murs
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député pour les écho les écologistes
Francesca passe Kuni
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général le harcèlement
scolaire persiste en France touchant 10%
des élèves au collège en 2021 et il est
évident qu'il est nécessaire d'adopter
des approches novatrices pour le contrer
les événements récents nous ont rappelé
combien il était difficile d'inverser
cette tendance à l'heure des réseaux
sociaux et de la numérisation des
interactions plusieurs pistes ont été
explorées ces dernières années pour y
faire face la politique de prévention
s'est organisée autour du programme
phare qui compte désormais sur un réseau
de 400 référents académiques et
départementaux répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire ce réseau est chargé de
gérer les cas de harcèlement signalés
par les chefs d'établissement en
utilisant les plateformes 30 20 et 30 18
pour traiter les cas de
cyber-harcèlement cependant les
tentatives de sensibilisation en
elle-même se sont révélées en
suffisantes à court terme ce qui
souligne l'importance de combiner la
sensibilisation avec des actions
concrètes sur les terrains une enquête
de l'INJEP a mis en lumière que la
simple diffusion d'information n'a pas
nécessairement d'effets significatif sur
la prévalence du harcèlement le
bien-être des élèves ni leur performance
scolaires les capitales de reconnaître
que la responsabilité de la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire ne peut reposer
exclusivement sur les enseignants même
si l'amélioration de leur formation
initiale est continue demeure
essentielle pour aller plus loin le
ministre a évoqué la possibilité de
mettre en place des cours d'éducation à
l'empathie sur le modèle des dispositifs
déployés au Danemark cette piste
prometteuse et les écologistes
soutiennent cette initiative afin de
permettre aux enfants de mieux
comprendre leurs émotions et celles des
autres mais question seront donc les
suivantes quels moyens sont prévus pour
mettre en place cette expérimentation
comment articuler ces ateliers avec les
heures de classe déjà très chargés et
surtout avec la formation des
professeurs et est-ce que les
associations seront associées à ce
dispositif merci merci madame la députée
pour GDR Stéphane peu oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
général je vais essayer de vous poser
dans le temps imparti quatre questions
précises la première
concerne la promesse qui n'a pas été
tenue d'avoir un enseignant devant
chaque classe à la rentrée dans
l'académie de Créteil c'est 60% des
établissements dans lesquels il manquait
un professeur et c'est encore plus dans
mon département de la Seine-Saint-Denis
alors vous aviez beaucoup d'espoir dans
le pacte pouvez-vous nous dire combien
de pattes ont été signés et quel est le
pourcentage d'enseignants à avoir signé
le pack qui était censé régler beaucoup
de problèmes deuxième sujet la pénurie
de professeurs dans l'académie de
Créteil près de la moitié des postes
soumis au concours aux trois concours
non pas été pourvu et il nous est dit
que la note d'admission au concours
était de 4/20 dans l'académie de Créteil
quand dans la plupart des académies de
France la note de d'admission au
concours et de 14 x 20 pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que dans l'académie de Créteil
qui couvre les départements et les
quartiers populaires de l'Île-de-France
on recrute à 420
deuxième troisième question France
stratégie vient de sortir un rapport qui
confirme des choses que nous savions
beaucoup pour beaucoup déjà c'est que
l'école en France creuse les inégalités
sociales et ne les corrige pas
d'évaluation de ces pays en évaluation
de 6e en évaluation de seconde selon
l'origine sociale l'école vous
vous enferme si je puis dire dans votre
condition sociale pouvez-vous nous dire
les réflexions que ça inspire au
directeur que vous êtes en face
quatrième question et dernière question
on sait que la scolarité précoce a des
effets sur la réussite scolaire
ultérieure comme le souligne le Conseil
d'évaluation de l'école or
30 %
des
or pardon nous constatons une chute
importante de la scolarisation des deux
ans il représentait 30% au début des
années 2000 nous sommes tombés à 11%
quels sont les pistes pour corriger cela
merci Monsieur de député pour le groupe
liote Paul Molac
merci madame la Présidente donc
j'aimerais avoir votre analyse sur la
réforme du bac et est-ce que cette
réforme a été en mesure de d'augmenter
par exemple les résultats au bac et
vous avez parlé de la changer en fait
les épreuves de spécialité je crois que
c'est une excellente chose la deuxième
chose j'aimerais vous interroger sur
l'enseignement bilingue et la mise en
place de la loi du 21 mai 2021
les conventions qui ont été signées avec
un certain nombre de
régions en ce qui concerne en tout cas
la région Bretagne que je connais bien
nous avons un gros problème de
recrutement d'enseignants bilingue pour
pouvoir parler en breton j'ai fait une
demande pour que certaines enseignantes
qui sont en Bretagne et qui ne
retourneront pas dans leur académie
d'origine puisse avoir un exeat et le
recteur est l'inspecteur du Morbihan m'a
dit qu'il était prêt à les intégrer
parce que il y a des gros manques dans
le Morbihan et dans le Finistère
merci monsieur le député Monsieur le
Directeur général c'est à vous pour
répondre à cette première salle de
question
merci beaucoup alors je vais peut-être
commencer puisque vous avez été
plusieurs à m'interroger sur le sujet du
harcèlement et évidemment
suscite des réactions
partagées de douleur et de
mots voilà c'est nos élèves et donc
je crois qu'il y a pas de mots assez
fort pour dire la douleur collective et
le ministre vous l'avez rappelé
d'ailleurs et aussi des mots très forts
sur
les premiers éléments qu'on observe dans
la situation du jeune Nicolas dont vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure alors sur
cette affaire spécifique il y a une
enquête qui est en cours comme vous le
savez évidemment côté côté judiciaire
mais il y a surtout une enquête
administrative pour ce qui est de notre
de notre périmètre et notre
responsabilité
donc voilà je veux pas forcément
m'exprimer sur cette affaire là au-delà
de ce qu'a dit le ministre bien que je
ne pourrais le dire et avec des mots
dont évidemment tout de l'institution
partage la force et la et la
et la blessure qu'elle représente
vous avez été plus vous met du coup
interroger sur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par rapport à
ce fléau et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
par rapport à la réaction de
l'institution par rapport à ce fléau
alors il va évidemment y avoir un plan
un terminal qui va être annoncé annoncé
fin septembre qui je pense comportera
cet endroit de mesure novatrices donc
sur lesquelles évidemment je suis pas en
état de m'exprimer pour l'instant mais
d'ores et déjà il y a un certain nombre
de
d'éléments qui ont été annoncés par le
ministre
s'agissant d'abord de
la nécessaire
bonne réaction de l'administration
vous avez vu que le ministre a demandé à
ce qu'il y a un audit dans tous les
rectorats de France de toutes les
situations qui sont montées au cours de
l'année scolaire dernière et qu'on
regarde pour chacune de ces situations
la réponse qui a été apportée on a
besoin de comprendre comment
la réponse que vous avez évoquée tout à
l'heure a pu être apporté dans cette
situation et on a besoin par conséquent
de repenser l'organisation de la réponse
la qualité de la réponse la qualité
aussi du suivi dans le temps de ces
situations parce que de manière plus
générale quand on observe les situations
de harcèlement on est saisi ou qui sont
amenés à remonter au niveau national
notamment au niveau de ma direction
en fait ce qui est assez troublant
évidemment les situations qui ne sont
éventuellement pas vues pas comprise
parfois éventuellement sous-estimé
disons-le il y a aussi des situations et
même beaucoup de situations où il y a
bien eu une réaction de l'institution et
une réaction parfois même assez ferme en
termes de disciplinaire etc
mais où
d'une certaine manière la réponse y
compris dans sa fermeté
est considérée comme étant un peu le le
comment dire enfin clos finalement la
situation alors ce qu'on observe dans
ces situations extrêmement
compliquées c'est que il y a des formes
de réminiscence dans le temps et
l'espèce de
serpent de mer qui peut ressortir comme
ça quelques mois voire quelques années
après prendre une forme qu'on n'avait
pas revu etc et donc il faut qu'on
s'interroge collectivement non seulement
bien sûr sur l'ensemble de la posture de
réponse mais sur la procédure aussi ce
processus de suivi humain dans le temps
des jeunes qui ont été victimes de ces
comportements et de et de ces
traumatismes
la deuxième chose c'est que parce que
vous m'avez interrogé notamment sur la
question des sanctions notamment par
rapport aux cyber-harcèlement parce que
le cyber-harcèlement a quand même
profondément
bouleverser la façon enfin les
comportements
et donc mécaniquement les capacités de
réaction aussi de l'institution
aujourd'hui il y a quasiment pas une
situation de harcèlement qui n'est pas
son prolongement cyber
et avec du coup
des jeunes qui n'ont plus aucun espace
ni aucun temps pour échapper à leur
harceleur
ça c'est effrayant c'est à dire qu'il y
a plus de respiration non seulement il y
a harcèlement mais en plus il y a plus
de respiration possible et avec cette
espèce de système de bombardement sur
les réseaux sociaux de messages etc qui
est qui est effrayant bon
jusqu'à présent jusqu'à cet été
l'institution était démunie dès lors que
le cyber-harcèlement était commis par
des élèves d'un autre établissement
autrement dit je suis un élève d'un
tennissement a
mon voisin d'établissement B si je le
cyber-harcèle jusqu'au mois d'août son
chef établissant pouvait rien faire
parce que le périmètre disciplinaire du
chef établissement s'arrêtait au fait
commis entre élèves de l'établissement
il y a donc une première innovation cet
été qu'on est en train évidemment de
d'expliciter sur le terrain mais qui
pour moi est un aimant extrêmement
important de réponse aussi bien
qui est que désormais un chef
établissement peu sanctionner un élève
qui a commis des actes de
cyber-harcèlement y compris contre des
élèves d'autres établissements et donc
ça veut dire que désormais quand on aura
un système d'alerte disant Edward j'ai
effray a été harcelé par des ailes de
l'établissement B et on sait que ça peut
aussi se positionner sur des rivalités
familiales entre quartiers que sais-je
et bien le chef établissement de
l'établissement B pourra sanctionner
l'élève en question deuxième élément je
dis pourra mais en fait c'est pas pour
moi c'est devra
puisque la règle qui a été inscrite dans
les textes et
je pense qu'on peut tous compter sur
l'énergie du ministre et de et de ceux
qui qui servent l'institution pour pour
le faire respecter et c'est nouveau
aussi depuis le mois de août c'est que
désormais tout acte de harcèlement doit
faire l'objet d'une sanctions
c'est des vrais pour les actes commis à
l'encontre des personnels c'était il y
avait une ouverture de procédure
disciplinaire obligatoire uniquement
dans cette hypothèse désormais on a
ouvert en disant à partir du moment
harcèlement une procédure disciplinaire
doit nécessairement être ouverte
donc on a ces deux éléments le troisième
élément qui est assez nouveau aussi
enfin complètement nouveau c'est dans le
premier degré comme vous le savez mais
j'y reviens quand même parce que tout ça
à peine un mois de publication au
Journal c'est le fait aussi qu'on
désormais dans le premier degré on peut
changer
le harceleur d'école
vous savez qu'on a vécu pendant très
longtemps cette situation
harcelé qui grosso modo au bout d'un an
était parfois amené à partir pour
essayer de fuir ses agresseurs bon
la victime n'a pas fuir ses agresseurs
les agresseurs vont être sanctionnés et
être déplacés la victime de pouvoir
continuer sa scolarité normale et donc
on a un texte pareil qui date c'est le
même décret du 16 août 2023 qui organise
désormais la possibilité de changer
d'affectation un élève dans le premier
degré sans l'accord de ses parents
lorsqu'il a commis des faits de
harcèlement donc ça c'est si je peux
dire la réponse
on va dire en termes de sanctions mais
qui est quand même nous offre des
leviers importants
parallèlement à ça évidemment un enjeu
le ministre a appelé un électrochoc et
je pense que c'est électrochoc est en
train de parcourir l'ensemble de
l'institution sur ce que vous avez
relevé tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire sur
l'appréciation des faits alors
qualification
et sur le fait que on ne peut pas
minorer si je puis dire l'effet tel
qu'ils ont été rapportés par un enfant
on sait que c'est un sujet parfois
récurrent c'est une qualification
d'ailleurs qui si je puis me permettre
je crois et sans rien retirer la
responsabilité nationale mais qui va en
fait très au-delà cette idée que ce sont
des querelles d'enfants
elle est quand même assez répandue
voyez
dans notre dans notre corps social et
donc il y a une nécessité d'exigence
absolue par rapport à ça un enfant qui
rapporte une violence
ou qui dit avoir vu la violence exercée
sur un de ses camarades ce qui est
souvent un moyen de dénoncer les
violences et les mêmes victimes il
commence par dire tu sais à la tu sais
j'ai un copain qui est bon et ça se
passe comment et puis à la fin au bout
de 10 minutes en fait on découvre que
c'est lui
elle doit être systématiquement entendu
et accueilli pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse évidemment lui
donner toute sa portée et y répondre et
ça ça veut dire aussi évidemment
envisager un certain nombre d'éléments
de formation mais je pense que là dessus
le plan entamer ces sera amené
évidemment à développer énormément de
choses à dire d'autres choses donc je ne
veux pas m'aventurer trop loin mais
l'ambition sera évidemment très forte
je termine juste sur un point c'est la
question des numéros que vous avez
mentionnés et finalement un peu du
système d'alerte le système d'alerte
actuel aujourd'hui est le suivant
donc nous avons en fait un une structure
avec des référents académiques des
référents départementaux et des équipes
départementales
qui font face à un afflude de demande et
par rapport auquel d'ailleurs le
ministre a été amené à dire qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à aller renforcer en
tant que de besoin
et qui reçoivent en fait décidément de
trois origines la première famille sur
les cinémas qui viennent des
établissements eux-mêmes la deuxième
famille ce sont les appels qui sont
faits sur les lignes académiques mais
qui sont en fait assez nombreux et puis
nous avons ces deux numéros nationaux
qui sont le 30 20 et 30 18 que nous
avons raccordé à une application qui
s'appelle stop-harcèlement c'est à dire
que quand les personnes qui gèrent ces
numéros on connaissances d'une situation
de harcèlement qu'elles arrivent à
qualifier comme tel ou susceptibles
d'être qualifié comme tel elles nous
font une alerte en disant voilà avec
l'accord bien sûr de la personnalité de
la famille en disant voilà
Edward Jeffrey dans tel établissement
et victime d'actes qui
on va dire au minimum pose problème et
pour être écrit de harcèlement et donc
il faut agir et à ce moment-là ça
enclenche en fait un système de retomber
si je puis dire que l'ensemble de la
chaîne est informé le référent
académique le référent départemental des
référents établissements pour donner
évidemment une suite assez assez
situation
à partir de là la question que vous avez
posée
monsieur le député tout à l'heure sur
une cible de signalement en central
je suis assez
réservé c'est-à-dire qu'on a une mission
au niveau de la centrale donc une
mission de qui en fait élabore la
politique de prévention d'appui de
sanctions etc qui peut éventuellement
quand on est saisi de situation
individuelle évidemment intervenir ça
arrive très souvent qu'on reçoit une
situation individuelles et en direct et
on décroche notre téléphone et on
appelle l'ensemble des correspondants
locaux pour être sûr qu'il se passe
quelque chose et on est d'ailleurs dans
ces cas on arrive à suivre satisfait
simplement à l'échelle de l'institution
on créerait très probablement un
engorgement y compris temporel
qui ferait concevoir son CAP de mesure
de réagir toute la réactivité nécessaire
si tout était centralisé donc autant il
faut qu'on ait une animation un pilotage
territoire très fort et qu'on repense
l'ensemble de la réponse à ces
situations c'est le sens de l'audit qui
a lancé le ministre autant une
centralisation totale de tous les
situations
honnêtement
la masse me ferait craindre en fait
qu'on passe à côté de de d'une réponse
de qualité
bon voilà voilà ce harcèlement mais
peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion de
rebondir mais je vais pas non plus trop
vous trop trop saturé votre temps avec
avec mes réponses mais en tout cas voilà
sachez que un électrochoc est là et de
la réponse
juridique évidemment a été
considérablement renforcée la réponse
humaine
va être entièrement repensée
conformément à la volonté du ministre
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur le CNR
en pointant du doigt
le fait que quantitativement ce ne
serait pas la hauteur des attentes alors
moi je me permets de de
ne pas partager complètement cette
appréciation
tout simplement parce que donc on a à
peu près 55 000 entités scolaires
aujourd'hui
et en moins d'un an donc puisque le CNR
a été lancé dans son principe au mois de
au mois de août le 25 août après une
république la plateforme d'inscription a
été ouverte au mois de
novembre au octobre fin octobre 2022
donc
c'est une comme vous le savez il y a une
profondeur de concertation qui
[Musique]
pré part entre guillemets l'élaboration
du projet
et donc la plateforme de dépôt de projet
est ouverte au mois de janvier et les
premiers projets sont hébergement
février entre janvier février et juin
nous avons reçu
8500 projets
d'écoles ou établissements qui concerne
3 millions 100 mille élèves
donc ça veut dire que j'ai grosso modo
un établissement sur 6 qui aujourd'hui
un peu moins établissement sur 6 qui
adore c'est déjà déposer un projet
et après il y a évidemment un processus
de validation parce que j'ai pas de
valider n'importe quoi avec des
allers-retours avec un accompagnement
sur le terrain etc etc alors qui
effectivement peut avoir un effet
calendaire qui fait que ceux qui ont
déposé leurs projets le 30 juin n'ont
pas eu la réponse forcément pour la
rentrée d'où le fait qu'on passe de 8500
à 3500 mais sur les 3500 projets déposés
donc pardon j'ai eu mais c'est un projet
posé donc 3 millions d'euvres c'est
grosso modo un élève sur 4 puisqu'on a
12 millions d'élèves aujourd'hui et sur
les projets validés on est donc à un
million 115000 élèves concernés
c'est-à-dire plus d'un élève plus d'un
élève sur sur 11 et aujourd'hui dans le
dans le dispositif et avec une
allocation de moyens qui aujourd'hui
tangente les 50 millions d'euros pour
ces premiers projets
ensuite ces projets ils sont
effectivement divers et
[Musique]
c'est précisément en fait la règle du
jeu le pari du CNR c'est de se dire soit
alors on dit à tout le monde
ce qu'on fait d'habitude et
j'en exerce une partie de la
responsabilité on fait une belle
circulaire donc voilà on veut un
dispositif comme celui-ci jusqu'au
dernier bouton de guêtre avec X euros
par élève
alors ça marche sur beaucoup de sujets
et puis
c'est pas moi qui vais contredire un
mode de fonctionnement qui nous fait
encore parfois je suis amené à assumer
le la responsabilité enfin ça marche pas
toujours quand même et on a quand même
beaucoup d'équipes de terrain qui ont
des besoins très spécifiques qui rêvent
de monter des projets et qui quand même
depuis des années pardon les femmes
étaient toujours obligé de faire ça avec
des bouts de ficelle mais que de cerise
et l'objectif là c'est de se dire bah
écoutez maintenant on change de registre
vous avez un projet il tient la route
vous pensez que dans le contexte local
qui est le vôtre il peut changer la
trajectoire de réussite de vos élèves on
regarde avec vous on vous accompagne
évidemment c'est pas seulement on fait
un chèque et on vous l'envoie par la
poste on vous accompagne
on fait éventuellement suivre votre
projet par des chercheurs pour qui
ensuite corps aussi pour savoir ce qui
marche et puis effectivement on finance
et ça c'est un levier on a déjà observer
ça évidemment à Marseille avec Marseille
Oran mais de manière générale moi qui
rencontre très régulièrement des équipes
sur le sujet
c'est un levier quand même objectivement
assez considérable il faudrait
évidemment l'évaluer d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de processus d'évaluation
qui sont en cours de finalisation avec
l'ADEP et les chercheurs qui sont qui
lui sont associés mais en termes de
transformation du système
c'est quand même assez puissant et ça
n'empêche pas par ailleurs et notamment
dans le cadre du Pacte qu'on met en
place des dispositifs de soutien
sur les questions de on va dire post
recrutement
moyen et et finalement taux
d'encadrement alors
premièrement nous n'avons pas une
population scolaire stable nous avons
une population scolaire qui est en chute
et qui est en chute objectivement
drastique pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est que entre
2000 et 2015 on avait en France chaque
année entre 805 et 830 000 naissances à
peu près 800 par an en 2022 de mémoire
on est tombé à 720 ou 730 000
c'est aussi simple que ça on a perdu 100
000 naissances par an en l'espace de 5
ou 6 ans et donc le système scolaire
aujourd'hui mécaniquement c'est
mécanique quand une génération à 30 000
naissances de moins de simplement trois
ans plus tard vous êtes 30 000 élèves de
moins qui ont dans le système scolaire
sur la période
2017-2022 nous avons perdu 300000 dans
le système scolaire et sur la période
2022 2027 nous attendons en perte 500
000 donc ça fait 800000 élèves de moins
dans le système scolaire en moins de 10
ans
si nous suivions la courbe démographique
mécaniquement nous aurions été amenés
parce que les 300 000 ont été
essentiellement supprimés
si on avait suivi mécaniquement à
trajectoire à supprimer des milliers
d'emplois dans le premier degré depuis 5
ans et ce n'est pas ce qu'on a fait
et ils comprennent les manières on a on
a
on a absolument pas suivi la courbe de
la démographie sinon on aurait été dans
une situation bien autre et donc le taux
d'encadrement des enfin le nombre de
l'encadrement
en fait c'est globalement amélioré dans
le premier degré puisque si je reprends
les chiffres
à la rentrée 2016 en public en pré
élémentaire en maternelle on avait 24,3
enfants par classe en 2022 ont été à 22
en moyenne et un élémentaire ont été à
23,5 et on était tombé à 21,1 à la
rentrée 2022
donc on a objectivement une baisse du
nombre d'élèves par classe alors qui
évidemment
s'explique pour une petite partie par la
démographie qui s'explique aussi sur
évidemment par les dédoublements et puis
par les plafonnement
des mêmes au-delà de ça la démographie
si vous voulez y compris au-delà des
efforts qui ont été faits sur tel ou tel
classe enfin niveau de classe la
démographie évidemment un impact sur le
second degré selon qu'on est en collège
en lycée professionnel ou en lycée
général et technologique on a des
variations un peu différentes le collège
a plutôt vu le nombre d'élèves augmentés
très légèrement en cours de la période
puisqu'on est passé de 24,5 à 24,9 on
savait parce qu'il y avait une bulle
très particulière qui correspond
vraiment à bit démographique donc on
savait qu'il y aurait une bible sur deux
trois ans qui se forge qui se formerait
de ce point de vue là en lycée
professionnel vous mentionnez tout je
crois un standélément on est passé de 19
par division ou absolument à 17,6 et on
est le jeté on est passé de 27,9 à 27,4
et désormais nous sommes nous sommes sur
une courbe descendante en nombre délais
dans le second degré puisque depuis deux
ans pour la première fois nous avons
moins d'élèves qui entre en 6e c'est le
début en fait tout simplement de de la
de la cour démographique dont je parlais
tout à l'heure et donc le nombre
d'élèves commencent à baisser dans le
second degré
alors du coup
et pardon pour suivre mes images je
trouve important qu'on partage ces
chiffres donc pour pour rebondir sur les
questions que vous m'avez posées enfin
pour reprendre le fil des questions de
me poser
donc
par rapport à cette baisse et par
rapport à ces assez moyens
divers donc j'ai répondu sur la partie
effective des classes sur la partie
enseignant enfin nombre d'enseignants et
puis manque d'Ash et sur la façon de de
le résoudre alors bon d'abord je là
aussi je me permettrais mais c'est
purement technique de de pas enfin ne
pas me reconnaître dans le mot fiasco du
recrutement puisque chaque année nous
recrutons 20000 personnels ce qui fait
le nous je pense le premier recruteur de
France
sur sur tous l'hexagone et ensuite
c'est important aussi de savoir nous
avons de mémoire quelque chose je suis
pas le dégge qui serait plus zen de vous
donner les chiffres mais enfin je vous
dis cette mémoire on a quelque chose
comme 185000 candidats ou 200000
candidats je ne sais plus différents
concours de recrutement d'enseignants si
je rapporte ça une génération de donc
800 000 personnes ça veut dire qu'on a
quand même une personne sur quatre qui
qui s'interroge pour devenir professeur
donc je suis voyez voilà il y a pas il
faut réussir à cibler le bon endroit en
revanche on a deux réalités qui sont
importantes on avait des trucs qui en a
été géographique c'est-à-dire que pour
être clair on n'a pas de difficultés
dans 27 agréments sur 30 et on a des
difficultés essentiellement sur les
Académie française et encore plus depuis
deux ans parce que très clairement aussi
et c'est aussi on trouve les mêmes
comportements au niveau des familles et
de nos élèves on a aussi des changements
de comportement des familles pour être
clair notamment post covid vis-à-vis de
la région parisienne et de votre
activité de la région parisienne donc on
a un usage parisienne premièrement je
vais revenir sur notre activité globale
que je mineure pas mais c'est pour dire
que sur la partie recrutement stricte au
sensu on est sur un sujet qui est à la
fois territorial et qui est dans le
second degré est très axé et
malheureusement depuis longtemps vers
certaines disciplines
on va dire le taux de pression à
l'entrée au concours n'est pas du tout
le même comme vous le savez selon que je
suis en histoire-géo en physique en
mathématiques en lettres ou en allemand
bon
par ailleurs il y a globalement je suis
dans l'activité
dont je crois le gouvernement s'est
emparé depuis longtemps avec un centre
de mesure de réalisation que vous
connaissez et qui ont été notamment
encore consolidés cette année et qui
fait que aujourd'hui plus aucun
personnel ne rentre dans la carrière à
moins de 2100 euros net
lorsque je suis arrivé vous voyez c'est
assez intéressant parce que moi lorsque
je suis arrivé dans ce ministère comme
directeur général des ressources
humaines donc j'étais nommé en 2017
lorsque enfin un jeune néotitulaire qui
entrait il était à moins de 1600 euros
net par mois
il sera 2100 euros net en cette rentrée
donc il y a des éléments de valorisation
financière sur lesquelles il faut
évidemment
enfin qui ont déjà été pris qui vont
continuer à travailler je suppose le DGH
honnêtement serait plus à même de vous
répondre que moi parce que je ne suis
pas sûr de d'avoir tout la connaissance
fine de chaque échelon mais il y a très
clairement notamment sur la première
moitié de carrière un effort très
important qui a été fait de rattrapage
si je puis dire d'une situation
et le pack que vous Manchez tout à
l'heure permet aussi pour les
professeurs volontaires d'exercer des
missions complémentaires et de les voir
rémunérer à hauteur donc de 1250 euros
par mission alors me demandiez est-ce
que vous avez les chiffres du nombre de
pactes qui ont été souscrits alors à
date précisément non aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas parce que tout simplement
l'ensemble de nos constats de rentrée
sont un peu de décalés dans le temps
comme vous le savez on attend toujours
que la rentrée pardon de ça comme ça
mais que les choses se posent
les saisons politiques soient fait que
les services soient définitivement actés
que les derniers justement ont eu lieu
etc etc pour en fait constater
l'ensemble des éléments à la fois côté
effectifs élèves et côté professeur donc
aujourd'hui à date malheureusement je ne
suis pas capable de vous dire le nombre
de pactes qui ont été souscrits mais ce
sont des éléments évidemment qu'on aura
et que on sera évidemment en mesure de
vous communiquer au cours des prochains
mois mais à ce stade on l'a pas encore
parce que simplement c'est c'est trop
c'est trop précoce par rapport à nos
systèmes de remontées et
d'enregistrement
sur les aosh la question se pose un peu
dans les mêmes termes en termes
d'attractivité de du métier donc là
aussi les avais ça sont intervalorisés
de mémoire de 11% en cette en cette
rentrée
et puis il y a de manière générale
la question récurrente du de
l'articulation entre notamment les
tenses Square est en périscolaire pour
permettre à des avsh de pouvoir
travailler à temps complet on y
travaille évidemment avec les
collectivités territoriales
sur la dimension des savoirs
fondamentaux vous avez rappelé madame la
députée qu'il y avait 30% des enfants
qui arrivaient avec des difficultés en
français en 6e alors c'est 27% français
31% en mathématiques sont pas forcément
les mêmes d'ailleurs et vous nous avez
demandé ce qu'on pouvait faire alors
plusieurs choses d'abord effectivement
il y a tout un travail sur les pratiques
pédagogiques toute la difficulté étant
évidemment qu'on agit comme toujours
dans notre min on a des effets de
courtes c'est-à-dire que on n'apprend
pas à lire ou à écrire en sens complet
du terme en quelques mois et donc on ne
mesure les effets en fait de nos de nos
politiques que un an deux ans cinq ans
six ans après donc c'est évidemment
toujours un peu compliqué de d'apporter
une réponse catégorique mais on a très
clairement une évolution de nos
pratiques pédagogiques notamment
incarnée par les plans mathématiques et
puis en français j'ai évoquais le plan
lecture à Mayotte dont on voit qu'il
fonctionne c'est quand on a une
circonscription ou une école qui est
bénéficié entièrement enfin dans tous
les personnes ont bénéficié du plan
mathématique du plan français on observe
un résultat très concret l'exemple de
mémote étant évidemment paroxystique
parce que là c'est tous les professeurs
de CP de CE1 qui ont bénéficié ensemble
d'une formation par l'Inspection
générale et 18 mois 18 mois après on
reprend la photographie et on regarde et
on observe la progression sachant
d'ailleurs qu'on a fait exprès de
prendre je précise des éléments qui
étaient en te covid pour être sûr qu'on
puisse bien comparer
la situation donc aujourd'hui on sait
que associer notamment à des conditions
d'apprentissage renforcées ou améliorer
notamment les questions prioritaires la
pédagogie permet de dépasser un certain
nombre d'inégalités sociales ou
territoriales et de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs pardon d'y revenir mais
j'observe quand même que dans les
résultats des évaluations ce qu'on
constate c'est quand même en temps long
sur la période
2018-2022 et donc là on attend
évidemment pour le mois de novembre mais
c'est un des événements de son année
mais on constate une réduction des
écarts notamment entre l'éducation
prioritaire renforcée le hors éducation
prioritaire en CP en CE1 en 6e donc le
on n'est pas encore à la maille de ce
qu'on voudrait bien sûr mais
malgré tout ces écarts ils se réduisent
pour autant donc on a toujours un stand
d'élèves qui arrive en 6e avec des
difficultés alors deux éléments de
réponse par rapport à ça il y a un
élément si je puis dire de rétroaction
sur CM1 CM2 et un élément de
remédiation en 6e la rétroaction sur CM1
CM2 c'est effectivement
travailler les pratiques pédagogiques
notamment autour de la lecture et de
l'écriture en cours moyen on sait que
l'écriture en cours moyen
on a vu on a un rapport d'inspection
générale qui a montré que la pratique de
l'écriture avait tendance à s'étioler
encore moyen et c'est pour ça que le
ministre autre jour a été amené à le
redire avec beaucoup de force et en
refaire une priorité il a typiquement
mentionné dans les leçons pas dans les
exercices d'ailleurs mais dans les
leçons la question par exemple des
textes à trous il faut que les élèves
puissent recopier des phrases complètes
parce que une phrase complexe c'est
aussi la complexité d'une pensée c'est
une syntaxe et une grammaire etc donc il
y a ce travail là évidemment toi
écriture
et puis il y a le travail autour de la
lecture et de ce point de vue là comme
sur l'AS d'ailleurs je me permets de
souligner le travail remarquable de nos
collègues
à partir de mon on a commencé à mesurer
l'affluence à l'entrée en 6e donc
l'influence c'est la capacité à lire un
texte avec le ton et à témoigner de sa
compréhension de sa juste compréhension
pas seulement un débit de lecture
appartement est égal dans le mesurer on
avait partagé les résultats avec les
professeurs des écoles
on a constaté en direct l'amélioration
des résultats c'est-à-dire que les
professeurs des écoles ont repris ces
questions là les ont refait travailler
et qu'est-ce qu'on constate c'est que en
deux ans le nombre d'élèves en maîtrise
de fluence à l'entrée en 6e a augmenté
de 6 points on est passé de 50 à 56%
et en éducation prioritaire renforcée où
il était malheureusement moins bon
puisqu'il était seulement à 30% on est
passé à 39,8
donc
je dis ça parce que ça veut dire qu'il y
a une capacité de l'institution à
adapter ces pratiques pédagogiques à
partir du moment elle dispose des
éléments qui permettent de constater les
éventuelles difficultés et les corriger
qui est quand même très élevé grâce à
l'investissement des collègues
donc ça c'est la partie réaction et puis
à la partie remédiation en 6e et là
c'est là qu'on retrouve ces fameuses
heures de soutien d'approfondissement et
qu'il est essentiel de bien les monter
quelle est l'idée c'est que c'est pas la
moitié de la classe qui a moins de 12
reste en soutien l'autre moitié va en
approfondissement
c'est en partant notamment de ce que
nous disent les professeurs de CM2 et
des élévation intrants
à allumer mais assez camarades qui ont
des difficultés en fraction et ça c'est
important parce que quand on dit 27% des
élèves on est équipé en français etc en
fait ce qui est intéressant pour voir
les items c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
universel ils ont difficulté ici mais
pas là etc donc l'idée c'est d'avoir
vraiment cette approche très ciblée sur
la compétence pour permettre à chacun de
se de se redresser finalement la barre
et surtout de ne pas souffrir de ce
qu'on connaît bien c'est-à-dire que
malheureusement le collège a tendance à
le collège qui le fait mais au collège
la difficulté scolaire a tendance
statistiquement à se pérenniser
c'est-à-dire en difficulté
j'ai probablement une très grande
difficulté aussi à m'améliorer au cours
du collège alors que si on corrige très
vite en médiation en 6e on ouvre la
perspective de variance scolarité
réussie pour le reste du collège sur la
question des Proms et des manuels alors
vous avez été plusieurs à évoquer cette
question et sur la partie scientifique
d'Emmanuel donc comme vous le savez les
manuels la rédaction des manuels n'est
pas la responsabilité nationale autant
que les programmes avec conseils
indépendants etc autant nous n'avons pas
la responsabilité des manuels donc il y
a des questions récurrentes évidemment
sur cette sur ce sur cette situation
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas en mesure à date de vous dire autre
chose que que cela sur
pardon excusez-moi parce qu'en plus je
deviens presbyte ce qui est vraiment
problématique j'avais même pas volé si
pardon sur les questions donc de
des très petites section s que vous avez
posées donc là dessus le panneau qui est
ministre a annoncé leur volonté de les
dynamiser
donc évidemment ça prend ça prend un
petit peu de temps en circon c'est pas
ouvrir une très petite section au mois
d'août pour le mois de septembre mais en
revanche donc dans les projections qu'on
a pour l'année prochaine donc pour la
rentrée 2024 effectivement on va
remettre des moyens sur l'augmentation
des très petites sections
non seulement à Marseille mais plus
généralement obligation prioritaire et
notamment dans les cités éducatives ou
les quartiers politiques de la ville et
puis il y avait une question sur
l'analyse de la réforme du bac
alors sur le la réforme du enfin il y a
deux choses la réforme du C la réforme
du baccalauréat la réforme du lycée elle
s'est traduite quand même par la fin
d'une forme de sociologie des filières
et ça c'est intéressant 50% des élèves
aujourd'hui et c'est constant dans le
temps depuis 2019 la moitié des élèves
font des choix de spécialité aujourd'hui
qui ne correspondent pas aux anciennes
filières ses
et on a réussi à se départir de cette
question qui faisait grosso modo un
enfant de 4 faisait une s même quand il
avait absolument pas professionnel
pas
et là où d'autres là où les autres
enfants sur la partie sur les autres
filières ce qui est quand même moi en
tout cas je considère que c'était un
problème majeur en terme d'égalité
sociale et de et d'accès ensuite et de
rotation et d'accès au supérieur donc on
a résu cette question là d'une certaine
manière en permettant ce bouquet
deuxième élément important
il y a une très forte concordance entre
les choix spécialités les choix
d'orientation ce qui n'était pas le cas
à l'époque
troisième élément du coup les
spécialités servent de révélateur sur ce
qui était les choix d'orientation c'est
qu'en fait avant on était aveugle
jusqu'à la fin de la terminale puisque
les gens faisaient une s quand il
voulait faire médecine quand il voulait
faire machin quand il voulait faire
avocat alors que maintenant ils vous
disent ben moi je vais faire
physique-chimie SVT option maths
complémentaire en terminale quand je
vais faire médecine
et donc finalement ça a servi de
révélateur le choix des spécialités à
celui de révélateur des orientations des
orientations futures et de ce point de
vue d'ailleurs et avec une vous savez
qu'on a une très très grande vigilance
et engagement sur notamment la
trajectoire des filles en sciences mais
je relève que les filles sont 55 % donc
elles sont majoritaires à prendre la
triplette mat physique chimie SVT en
première on l'oublie en fait les profils
les plus scientifiques sont
majoritairement fait en première mais en
revanche elles abandonnent plus les
mathématiques ont terminé parce que se
tournent plus vers des filières type
médecine ou en fait elle garde l'option
Matt complémentaire mais pas la
spécialité maths au profit de
physique-chimie SVT dont elle considère
qu'elles sont plus utiles par rapport à
la alors chose d'après donc on a un
phénomène de ce type là mais en tout cas
on a une cohérence des choix
d'orientation et de la suite enfin des
sociétés de rotation beaucoup plus
grande qu'avant ce qui va falloir voir
dans le temps et c'est là qu'on manque
un peu de recul parce que finalement la
première corde va arriver cette année à
la fin de sa licence il va falloir qu'on
regarde dans le temps c'est si ça se
trouve par une amélioration des
résultats dans des supérieurs puisque
vous savez que l'un des constats c’était
que 60% des élèves ne faisaient pas leur
licence en trois ans et donc ça pour
l'instant je n'ai pas le recul suffisant
pour vous répondre sur le bac elle
aurait en tant que tel le ministre a été
amené à l'annoncer avec le report des
épreuves au mois de juin voilà les
épreuves au mois de mars ont soulevé un
stand de difficulté c'est clair
donc ça a été ça a été fait ça a été
voilà bon voilà il y a des difficultés
qui ont été révélées et donc à partir de
là le choix a été fait de les remettre
au mois de juin pour précisément
résoudre ces difficultés donc ça ne
change pas la nature des épreuves dans
leur contenu évidemment au sens le type
de compétences testées
en revanche ça permet effectivement
d'avoir une année
libérée si je puis dire de tout examen
pour les apprentissages et donc une
implication des élèves jusqu'à la fin de
l'année c'est quand même la condition
non seulement de risque mais aussi de
réussite dans l'enseignement supérieur
voilà pardon j'étais un peu long mais
j'espère en faire près de questions
merci vous avez été exhaustif dans les
réponses mais je suis quand même
persuadé que mes collègues auront encore
des questions ou des précisions à vous
demander et donc nous allons commencer
par Stéphane Mazar pour une minute
merci Madame la présente Monsieur le
Directeur c'est par un heureux hasard de
calendrier que nous vous auditionnons en
cette Journée nationale du sport
scolaire la question est importante car
l'urgence est absolue en tant que
corps-à-porteur avec Stéphane peu d'une
émission sur les jeux et leur héritage
j'ai pu nous avons pu observer dans nos
auditions les effets délétères du manque
d'activité physique sur nos jeunes
monsieur Jeffrey ou en sommes-nous des
mesures d'ampleur inédites que ce
gouvernement a pris en faveur du sport
scolaire pouvez-vous nous dire comment
cela se présente en cette année
concrètement dans les établissements
concernant en particulier les 30 minutes
de la PQ qui si elles sont aujourd'hui
généralisées en théorie rencontre des
problèmes de mise en œuvre
effective par ailleurs avez-vous observé
une montée en puissance des dispositifs
label génération 2024 ou encore du
programme univers 2024 plus généralement
Monsieur le Directeur peut-on espérer
que notre école sera véritablement se
saisir de l'occasion des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques pour développer une
véritable culture sportive comme cela
devient urgent merci Monsieur député
Anne bruniera
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général pour vous
propose l'imminaire question concernera
la reconquête du mois de juin qui est
une priorité de notre ministre et de
votre ministère j'ai salué quant à moi
la décision de du ministre de décalé au
mois de juin les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat cela en effet bien sûr
sur nos élèves de terminale mais il
convient aussi de penser à nos
collégiens et lycéens qui sont 30 à 40%
selon les chiffres des syndicats à
perdre des heures d'enseignement au
troisième trimestre j'ai changé avec des
enseignants il y a peu à l'occasion de
la rentrée qui m'ont parlé bien sûr des
difficultés bâtimentaires de
disponibilité des locaux notamment
pendant les épreuves et les différents
brevets baccalauréat à passer mais aussi
la disponibilité des enseignants
pouvez-vous nous dire quels sont les
freins pour cette reconquête et quels
sont les pistes envisagées je pense plus
spécialement quand même à nos collégiens
pour lesquels j'ai entendu aussi les
inquiétudes de parents grandissantes
merci merci Madame la député Alexis
Corbière
un mot pour ce qui est selon le ministre
la grande cause de son mandat la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire certes
grande cause mais petit moyen comment
comprendre que Monsieur le Ministre à
dernièrement dit que si il a mis un si
il a besoin de moyens supplémentaires
pour constituer des équipes chargées à
plein temps de gérer les dossiers de
harcèlement etc Il les mettrai les
moyens et que nous sommes actuellement
selon le syndicat majoritaire à
l'éducation nationale à moins 15000
infirmières scolaires 15000 et nous
avons régressé depuis que vous êtes en
responsabilité non pas vraiment une
prise en la République vu que nous
sommes passés de 1143 médecins scolaires
à 843 aujourd'hui en 2021 et 8500 en
2017 infirmier et 7500 aujourd'hui ça
c'est en constat alors au-delà des mots
il y a les faits lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire c'est au moins
qu'il y ait une oreille qui existe dans
nos établissements scolaires une
infirmière une psychologue un médecin
ils ne sont pas là dans ma
circonscription dans mon département
c'est particulièrement caricatural nous
avons manifesté encore dernièrement
auprès de la direction académique pour
avoir ne serait-ce que dans nos
collègues
oui ou une infirmière ou une assistance
ce qui n'est pas le cas donc j'aimerais
que
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
soit pas l'objet seulement de la
communication mais aussi de fait et en
dernier mot une question sur ce qui
s'est passé dans l'établissement
scolaire ou la police est intervenue en
classe monsieur le député c'est rentré
pour la première fois scolaire
interprète merci monsieur le député donc
Maxime minot
présidente monsieur le directeur général
j'ai été sollicité hier par Madame le
Maire de Brenouille une commune de
matières conscription concernant
l'accueil de ime au sein de son école en
dehors du temps scolaire à partir de
cette rentrée
pourquoi un pose-t-on à cette commune de
2000 habitants d'établir une convention
pour annoncernement de la langue arabe à
combien d'élèves s'adresse-t-il
pouvez-vous me confirmer qu'elle est
dans son droit de refuser cet accueil
non préparé en amont un travail
préparatoire par les services de la
DSDEN ou de l'inspectrice de l'éducation
nationale de la circonscription n'est-il
pas été plus opportun et au-delà du
procédé très cavalier d'imposer un
dispositif hors éducation nationale sans
concertation préalable il convient
également me semble-t-il de questionner
l'utilisation même des locaux communaux
sans l'accord des élus entre les APC et
les stages de réussite le soutien aux
élèves dans le cadre du Pacte enseignant
quelle est la marge de manœuvre pour ces
petites communes qui doivent étendre les
horaires des agents pour la fermeture de
ces lieux et qui devait également
supporter des charges non prévues je
pense également aux Jeux de clés au
chauffage électricité au nettoyage
complémentaire n'est-il pas nécessaire
de concerter davantage et de réfléchir
un partenariat plus serein avec les élus
locaux merci merci monsieur le député
Graziella Melker
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous remercie pour
vos propos liminaires et notamment ce
relatif au harcèlement scolaire qui
au-delà du phénomène d'actualité doit se
traiter sur le temps long et je suis
convaincue que nous parviendrons
ensemble à porter un plan pour les
radiquer je souhaitais cependant vous
interroger sur un tout autre sujet que
rapporteur d'une mission relative à
l'adaptation de l'école aux enjeux
climatiques je souhaitais avoir votre
avis sur une potentielle modification de
l'agenda scolaire et des zonage de
vacances à l'aune du changement
climatique est-ce que des idées qui vont
dans ce sens vous semblent plus
pertinentes que d'autres il devient en
effet de plus en plus difficile de
concevoir la tenue de classe à des
températures avoisinant les 40 degrés
mais est-ce que la reconquête scolaire
des mois d'été ne va pas à l'encontre
des enjeux climatiques comment résoudre
cette équation par ailleurs si votre
direction est compétente pensez-vous
qu'il serait souhaitable de renforcer
l'enseignement développement durable et
de sanctuariser éventuellement un
créneau pour un cours à part entière je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
Gérald ine Bannier
merci sur le sujet du harcèlement
difficile je crains pour ma part qui ne
soit qui n'exacerbe un esprit
d'animosité à l'égard de l'éducation
nationale et de ses agents et ne
viennent durcir encore un sujet
fondamental dont on entend peu parler
c'est celui de la relation entre parents
et professeurs
c'est une relation qui se passe
heureusement bien dans la plupart des
cas mais elle est parfois inexistante ou
alors clairement parfois détérioré
évidemment c'est un sujet qui demande la
cohésion de tous il relève du devoir
parental d'être vigilant pour que les
enfants ne fassent jamais partie des
harceleurs n'est pas accès aux réseaux
sociaux sont surveillance pour rappel
l'âge de la majorité numérique que nous
avons adopté est 15 ans il faut
appliquer cette règle il relevait aussi
de l'ensemble des adultes des
communautés éducatives d'être en veille
permanente attentif au moindre signe
bien évidemment
évidemment je réussis à vous ce souhait
que parent et professeur se soutiennent
que la société reste reconnaissante par
rapport à la tâche difficile les
professeurs des éducateurs sont quoi on
y arrivera pas la situation nécessite
aussi il me semble prise de conscience
une réflexion par rapport à ce qu'il
peut faire naître autant de violence au
sein des groupes en 2023 sans être
nostalgique à l'extrême il me semble
qu'on faisait beaucoup mieux avant pour
préserver les enfants notamment de la
violence sur les écrans je voudrais vous
interroger sur le soutien psychologique
ce qui est prévu en termes de soutien
psychologique psychiatrique à des
équipes éducatives qui parfois n'ont pas
des soutiens
Monsieur le Directeur général je vous
remercie mon collègue Corbière d'avoir
enfin parler la problématique des
personnels médicaux sociaux assistante
sociale psychologue infirmière médecin
scolaire ils sont des piliers essentiels
des établissements scolaires dont on ne
parle pas ou trop peu j'avais déjà
évoqué ici mon expérience en
Seine-Saint-Denis où je n'ai pas connu
en six ans une équipe complète si ce
n'est une équipe du tout mais
aujourd'hui situation est la même dans
la ruralité je prendrai l'exemple de ma
commune de Laurent Sainte-Marie de
collège un lycée général de lycée pro
pas une seule assistante sociale alors
Monsieur le Directeur Général pour
lutter contre les inégalités scolaires
contre les inégalités sociales contre le
srment scolaire au quotidien et
permettre d'enseignants de ce qu'on crée
pleinement à leur mission il serait
peut-être temps d'envisager un grand
plan de recrutement et de revalorisation
de ces personnels qui sont essentiels
dans la vie de nos établissements qu'on
oublie trop souvent et j'y ajoute
également les CPE qui sont bien souvent
trop peu nombreux soit un CPE pour 400
ou 500 élèves qui n'est pas du tout
acceptable et on nous a souvent répondu
le problème est à Bercy j'espère que
j'aurai une autre réponse que la
question financière de Bercy merci
monsieur le député c'est une Calvez
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général je voudrais vous
parler de l'orientation l'orientation
c'est basé sur l'émancipation pour les
élèves mais c'est aussi une histoire de
mobilisation on a ces dernières années
plus procéder nous le faisons encore sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel sur la
mise en place des découvertes des
métiers j'aimerais savoir ce sera ma
première question où en est-on la
généralisation de ces modules de
découverte des métiers des la cinquième
autre point puisque il s'agit aussi de
renforcer les liens qu'il existe entre
les acteurs du monde économique et les
attentes et les acteurs du monde de
l'éducation je voulais savoir quel est
devenir le centre d'études et de
formation en partenariat avec les
entreprises et les professions qui
offrent des stages à des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale pour découvrir le
monde de l'entreprise je pense que ça
contribue vraiment à une compréhension
mutuelle aujourd'hui les offres et le
catalogue de stage n'est plus en ligne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
qu'il n'est pas oublié et que nous
pourront encore continuer je vous
remercie merci madame la députée Léo
Walter
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général ancêtre rentrée force
et de constater que le choc
d'attractivité n'a pas eu lieu le
salaire des enseignants français
toujours nettement inférieur à la
moyenne de l'OCDE on est à mon avis la
cause principale on est bien loin de la
promesse de Jean-Michel Blanquer de
maître le paquet pour faire du
professeur français l'un des mieux payés
d'Europe mais il existe une autre
injustice moins connue la note de
l'Insee du 29 juin dernier confirme que
le salaire net des enseignants est
inférieur de près de 1000 euros par mois
à celui des autres cadres A de la
fonction publique d'État ma question
s'adresse plus au DRH que vous étiez au
DG SCO cependant comme j'ai interpellé
papenga il y a plusieurs reprises sans
obtenir de réponse et comme les
ministres passent et que vous restez je
vous la pose tout de même comment le
ministère compte-t-il réduire cet écart
incompréhensible la réponse actuelle on
la connaît c'est le pacte or les
remontées du terrain sont sans appel
moins d'un quart des briques ont trouvé
preneur vous nous dites ne pas être en
mesure de confirmer ce chiffre mais le
prendriez-vous pour un échec ou
diriez-vous que ça n'a pas marché je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
Alexandre portier merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur directeur j'aurais
trois questions la première sur les
postes non-bourvus en la rentrée 2023 à
la fin des concours il restait 3100
postes qui étaient vacances les
syndicats ont recensaient 1200 encore
vacant à la rentrée c'est un chiffre que
le ministre conteste et je voulais
comprendre les raisons de ce décalage
deuxième question la mise en place du
plan pour élever le niveau scolaire on
l'a évoqué plusieurs fois ici les
classements sont assez désastreux
d'années en année les élèves de 4e ont
aujourd'hui un niveau d'élèves de 5e il
y a 25 ans donc la chute et aujourd'hui
incontesté et incontestable vous avez
évoqué plusieurs dispositifs et
notamment l'heure de renforcement mise
en place en 6e je voudrais savoir
matériellement concrètement qu'il
apporte au sein des établissements quel
type d'enseignant est-ce que ce sont les
professeurs des écoles comme ça a été
évoqué un moment ou d'autres enseignants
et troisième question la défiance des
parents vis-à-vis du ministère il y a
aujourd'hui une crise de confiance qui
est manifeste 69% des parents font peu
confiance au gouvernement pour résoudre
les violences à l'école 67% ne le font
pas confiance pour lutter contre le
mal-être des enseignants 68% ne font pas
confiance au gouvernement pour enrayer
la baisse du niveau comment expliquer
vous ou telle crise de confiance des
parents dans notre école je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
Jean-Claude Roy
en plus dès qu'un jour du séjour de
cohésion au nom des promesses
présidentielles ne risque-t-on pas de
d'essuyer les plâtres de cette marche
forcée merci monsieur le député Fabienne
Colboc
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur la rentrée scolaire de
cette année s'est passé dans des
meilleures conditions que l'année
précédente et cela s'explique par
différents facteurs d'abord parce qu'on
a mieux recruté au concours de cette
année avec une augmentation de 7,4%
d'admis dans le premier degré une hausse
de 6% dans le second degré et puis parce
que les académies ont pu anticiper les
recrutements de contractuels plus
efficacement que les années précédentes
cependant ces derniers sont souvent
informés au dernier moment des
remplacements qu'ils doivent effectuer
ou pas ainsi comment pouvons-nous mieux
anticiper les besoins et organiser le
travail de ces contractuels dans une
stratégie RH plus bienveillante pour
elle pour eux
merci madame la députée Emmanuel
Pellerin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général lia générative est un
sujet majeur une majorité d'élèves
l'utilisent déjà au lieu d'interdire son
usage il est essentiel de former nos
élèves à une utilisation judicieuse ce
qui suppose de préparer nos enseignants
à cette tâche ma question est la
suivante quelles sont vos plans pour une
formation continue qui les aidera à
comprendre à intégrer cette technologie
de manière éthique et efficace tout en
équilibrant les savoirs traditionnels et
les compétences numériques de nos élèves
merci infiniment merci monsieur le
député Sarah Legrain
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général de l'enseignement
scolaire aujourd'hui les yeux étaient
rivés sur un ancien élève de l'école
privée censé faire ses premiers pas à
l'école publique je fais bien sûr à
l'usure à Monsieur le Ministre Gabriel
Attal en immersion dans un lycée mais je
voudrais vous parler ici du phénomène
inverse celui des élèves qui cette année
vont quitter l'école publique pour un
établissement privé j'ai été frappé moi
en cette rentrée par le nombre de
parents qui m'ont dit de voir mettre à
contrecoeur leurs enfants dans le privé
à contrecoeur parce que cela heurte leur
conviction politique voire religieuse et
en même temps que cela vient peser sur
le budget familial déjà durement touché
par l'inflation un père me parlait de sa
fille victime de harcèlement qui ne
voulait plus retourner dans son collège
une mère me parlait de l'absence d'avsh
pour son fils en situation de handicap
enfin il y a eu ce cri d'un père qui m'a
marqué c'est triste à dire mais au moins
dans le privé je sais qu'il y aura des
professeurs devant mes enfants je doute
que ce phénomène ne concerne que ma
circonscription du Nord-Est parisien
mais impossible de trouver des chiffres
dans les documents que le ministère nous
transmette alors Monsieur le Directeur
quels sont vos chiffres sur ce transfert
du public au privé et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale quoi qu'on peuplée
d'amis de l'enseignement privé censé
être le garant de l'école républicaine
c'est-à-dire public laïque gratuite pour
toutes et tous peut-il se satisfaire
d'un tel transfert d'une telle défiance
des parents à l'égarder
Emmanuel Antoine
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général je souhaiterais
revenir sur la suppression ou les
suppressions de postes d'enseignants
dans le second degré en vue de cette
rentrée scolaire de septembre 2023 le
gouvernement a prévu dans la loi de
finances pour 2023 de supprimer 481
emplois d'enseignant dans le second
degré après en avoir et vous le savez
bien déjà supprimer plus de 2200 au
cours des toutes dernières années ni
suppression de postes annoncés
interviennent dans un contexte
croissance des effectifs scolarisés dans
le secondaire ces choix du ministère
interrogent tant ils apparaissent
préjudiciaires à la qualité des
conditions d'enseignement ainsi par
exemple dans ma circonscription collège
Denis Brunet collège rural pour les
classes de 3e il manque un enseignant de
mathématiques pour ceux de quatrième un
enseignant de mathématiques et de
français on ne sait pas quand ils ces
posteront pourvu des postes
d'enseignants vont ainsi être supprimés
dans certaines matières ce qui va
contraindre les collègues à assurer un
nombre excessivement élevé d'heures
supplémentaires il sera en doute plus
difficile d'organiser des temps
d'enseignement en effectif allégés en
dépit des injonctions en ce sens et de
la Cour des comptes alors ne faudrait
dire
de ressources humaines dans
l'enseignement secondaire merci
Bertrand sort
désolé le sujet était important
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général j'aurais aimé vous
interroger sur les effectifs et les
moyens humains des sections
d'enseignement général et professionnels
adaptés les classes de SEGPA qui se
trouve dans les collèges je voudrais
aussi insister sur l'excellent travail
qui est accompagné qui est effectué
pardon par les professeurs des écoles
spécialisés ainsi que les professeurs de
lycée professionnel les récentes
témoignages tendent à montrer que les
effectifs diminuent et que les moyens
humains mis à disposition sont également
en baisse est-ce que vous pourriez nous
faire un état des lieux de cette rentrée
comparativement à l'année scolaire
précédente d'autre part on a évoqué tout
à l'heure les dramatiques situation de
harcèlement je voudrais également vous
alerter sur ces élèves de SEGPA qui
souvent sont stigmatisés pour certains
malheureusement harceler ce qui ajoute à
la difficulté scolaire qu'il rencontre
une souffrance psychologique et morale
très forte donc je voudrais savoir
également si il est prévu que des
actions spécifiques soient mises en
place pour faciliter l'in clusion de ses
élèves au sein des collèges et éviter
ces situations de stigmatisation je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
belkhirt Benhaddad
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général l'État a choisi de
permettre plus de 200
000 jeunes de découvrir sur leur temps
scolaire les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 à travers la
billetterie populaire demandez
département c'est 500 jeunes mozélande
qui pourront participer à cet événement
porteur de valeur de diversité
d'inclusion nécessaire pour accompagner
le changement du regard de la société
sur le handicap la question du
financement du transport se pose
notamment pour les établissements des
territoires éloignés de la capitale la
crainte et de voir des établissements
scolaires renoncés à organiser ce voyage
pour des raisons budgétaires de fait
cela conduirait une discrimination
territoriale des solutions de
financement peuvent être trouvées en
partie avec un accompagnement des
collectivités locataires et
territoriales partenaires privilégiés
des écoles collèges et lycées ma
question à la suivante a-t-il été prévu
des financements pour pallier les frais
de transport et l'hébergement en soutien
aux établissements scolaires merci merci
Monsieur député Fabrice le vigoureux
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur général je souhaiterais
avoir des précisions sur la révision du
calendrier de l'éducation prioritaire
comme vous le savez certains collèges à
quand le collège du noix par exemple
présente toutes les caractéristiques
d'un collège réplique sans pour autant
bénéficier de ce classement la mission
présidée par notre collègue judo est
rapporté par notre collègue Carel dans
le prolongement du rapport Matthieu
Azema a montré la nécessité de cette
révision en préconisant une allocation
progressive de moyens en plus de
sacraliser les collèges red plus je
voulais savoir où en était les choses à
ce niveau là et ça me paraît un dossier
urgent très attendu par certains
collèges je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député Véronique Riotton merci Madame
Zidane Monsieur le Directeur général le
ministre au mois de juin dernier à
engager le renforcement pour la mise en
œuvre effective de l'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective et Amanda thé pour
cela le Conseil supérieur des programmes
avec un agenda à décembre de cette année
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
cet agenda s'il vous plaît
merci madame la députée Monsieur le
Directeur c'est à vous pour la suite des
questions et donc la suite des réponses
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup alors
peut-être sur l'ensemble des questions
sport sport scolaire donc évidemment une
ambition vous l'avez dit qui est
extrêmement extrêmement forte alors
j'envoie d'ailleurs sur la première
dentaire que la billetterie populaire
avec ce qu'on appelle ma classe au jeu
donc il y a
193500 billets qui vont être distribués
aux écoles
donc simplement alors actuellement on
est encore dans la phase de l'appel à
manifestation intéressée en fait on a
ouvert en disant voilà
signalez-vous avec des en fait des lots
concrètement de billets qui permettent
d'avoir la foi les élèves et les
accompagnateurs
l'idée étant évidemment d'avoir une
répartition territoriale une
distribution territoriale qui soit la
plus équilibrée possible donc pour
l'instant on a cette phase là
ensuite on ignore pas effectivement
qu'il y a cette question de comment
est-ce qu'on paye le transport etc etc
donc
pour être tout à fait clair on a bien en
tête la question
on va voir ensuite très probablement
académie par Academy en fonction des des
manifestations intérêts qui auront lieu
comme on fera mais enfin on a bien cette
on a bien cette dimension là à l'esprit
sur la partie sport pratique sportive on
a en fait on a trois enjeux on a un
premier enjeu qui est
comment dire renforcer l'activité
physique pour tous parce que c'est dans
ta réalité etc que tout le monde connaît
on a une deuxième partie qui est fait en
sorte que ceux qui ont des compétences
ou des talents particuliers puissent en
faire plus être mieux accompagné et puis
on a la partie troisième dimension qui
est comment est-ce que finalement on
construit une forme de culture générale
sportive notamment la perspective des
Jeux Olympiques sur le premier point
donc les 30 minutes de d'activité
physique quotidiennes dans les écoles
elles ont été généralisées à la rentrée
22 donc en fait on a un an de recul sur
on va dire le la massification du
dispositif on a fait une enquête assez
précise auprès des directeurs d'école
qui a montré
des choses assez intéressantes
globalement on va dire dans la majorité
des écoles ce sont approprié le
dispositif en revanche c'est rester un
phénomène qui est resté très à l'échelle
du professeur dans sa classe donc il y a
un travail collectif à travailler et 77%
des professeurs ont indiqué de ne pas
avoir été suffisamment accompagné dans
le déploiement et dispositif et donc ça
veut dire que tout à fait transparent
pas plus tard qu'il y a une dizaine de
jours on a réuni tous les référents les
trois petites vécu du territoire pour
justement travailler sur cet
accompagnement sur la mise à
dispositions de ressources etc avec
d'ailleurs un élément important c'est
que beaucoup considèrent qu'en fait ces
30 000 activités physiques
quotidienne elle devrait entre
guillemets 30 minutes de sport or en
dire c'est d'activité physique
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas obligé
avoir une tenue particulière on est
obligé d'avoir un terrain d'entraînement
ou que sais-je l'idée c'est de mettre en
mouvement
nos jeunes qui sont sédentaires c'est
pas forcément de leur faire faire on va
dire tel ou tel sport particulier au
niveau des collèges donc je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure 700 collèges qui sont
engagés en dispositif des douleurs de
sport en plus et puis une réflexion sur
les sections sportives scolaires et les
sections d'excellence sportive qui sont
les deux dispositifs qui permettent à
des jeunes de faire plus de sport
au collège pour là aussi en renforcer
l'efficacité c'est une commande qui nous
a été passée par la ministre des Sports
et ministre d'obligation nationale le
troisième élément sa culture générale
sportive si vous permettez cette
expression c'est refaire en sorte c'est
une partie de l'héritage des JO 2024
fait en sorte que tous les élèves de
France finalement ce soit familiarisé
avec avec ces sujets de sport donc on a
évidemment la dimension génération 2024
qui aujourd'hui maintenant à peu près
stabilisé mais qui mais qui évidemment
très puissante
c'est bon à l'instant même j'ai pu le
chiffre en tête mais je faisais ça de
vous retrouver ça sur le nombre de
d'écoles établissements qui sont engagés
et c'est aussi le fait que on va mettre
à disposition un stand de ressources on
a commencé par vous cacher d'ailleurs
hier si vous voulez aller voir le site
du SCOL tous les mois nous faisons un
mois un thème et nous mettons à
disposition des ressources pour ce que
les professeurs puissent évoquer l'une
des dimensions des Jeux Olympiques tout
au long de l'année pour aussi rythmer et
puis finalement faire rentrer le sport
pas seulement par la pratique mais par
la connaissance de ce qui est le sport
de ce que sont ces valeurs de
l'universalisme etc sur la partie
on va dire reconquête du mois de juin et
année scolaire en général du coup comme
ça je réunis des questions calendaires
et notamment liées aux questions de
transition écologique donc
la reconquête du mois de juin alors on a
deux on a demandé de quelles étaient les
freins
très clairement au niveau du lycée
l'un des éléments de difficulté c'est
évidemment la tenue des examens
la deuxième main et le succès aux
examens conditionnant ensuite
l'inscription dans le supérieur on peut
pas faire on va distribuer les résultats
du baccalauréat le premier août voilà on
fait en sorte que tombe toujours à peu
près la même date vers le entre le 7 et
le 10 juillet chaque année donc
évidemment il y a une rétroaction
puisque les professeurs sont mobilisés à
la fois sur les euros sur les écrits etc
le fait de remettre déjà les épreuves du
mois de mars Au mois de juin fait qu'on
va pouvoir faire récupérer le temps qui
avait été perdu cette année en mars
alors même que de façon mois de juin il
y avait déjà des épreuves et qui en fait
on avait un peu la double à peine enfin
la double la double difficulté donc
cette année on a plus de si je puis dire
de saut de haie on va directement au
mois de juin et donc ça va être un
premier élément le ministre a appelé
d'ailleurs à communiquer très
prochainement sur le calendrier
retenu par rapport à ça
sur le collège
la principale question qui se pose en
fait pour les élèves c'est le calendrier
de l'affectation et en fait par
rétroaction le calendrier des conseils
de classe avec une difficulté c'est
qu'une fois que vous enlève de 3e et un
peu l'impression que bon l'année est
finie et donc pour être tout à fait
complet le ministre nous a demandé de
travailler
en ce moment même là sur l'ensemble de
la procédure
d'affectation et de rotation des élèves
pour précisément faire en sorte d'abord
que si vous soit plus fluide mais aussi
qu'elles permettent de maintenir en
activité nos élèves en apprentissage
élève jusqu'à la fin de l'année scolaire
sur la question que vous avez posée le
députés sur la relation entre
le les enjeux climatiques et les garder
ce scanner alors c'est une question sur
laquelle évidemment c'est penché alors
malheureusement avec une comment dire le
les systèmes de référence changent
notamment calendaires on est entre
guillemets plus sûr de rien parce que si
on avait parlé l'année dernière on se
serait dit le mois de juin est trop
chaud si on en avait parlé le premier
septembre on serait dit au mois de
septembre est trop chaud donc on a d'un
côté l'enjeu du bâti et puis de l'autre
la question de savoir effectivement
comment est-ce qu'on adapte soit les
pratiques pédagogiques soient les
calendriers à tous ces à tous ces
éléments donc ça fait partie des
éléments qui ont été portés également
c'est ce passage on vient au travail
avec au niveau du Conseil fabrication
qui qui réfléchit là-dessus très
honnêtement à ce stade la solution
évidente ne s'impose pas c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire
sur les questions de médecine scolaire
d'infirmiers scolaire de et de et de et
en lien avec le harcèlement alors
plusieurs éléments premièrement
[Musique]
et j'en suis profondément convaincu la
prise en charge des situations de
prévention et de détection et de
traitement assuré sur harcèlement elle
est par nature collégiale et implique
par nature dans son des personnages
parce qu'un jeune il va en fait se
tourner au bout d'un moment vers un
adulte de confiance pourquoi celui-ci
plutôt qu'un autre il est le seul à le
savoir d'ailleurs
il va aller au bout d'un moment parler
avec quelqu'un ça peut effectivement
être infirmière scolaire au médecin
scolaire ça peut être très souvent
professeur ça peut être un CPE ça peut
être un AED ça peut être voilà donc
cette démarche là elle doit pas naturel
évidemment la médecine scolaire a un
rôle important à jouer dans ce domaine
alors sur le film scolaire
on a un problème
récurrent qui n'est pas en fait un
problème de nombre de postes le nombre
de postes de médecins scolaires sauf
erreur n'a pas diminué au cours des
dernières années en revanche le nombre
de postes de nombre de postes pourvu
et de personnes
comment dire de moyens pour les pour les
pour les recruter entre guillemets
aujourd'hui budgétairement en aide
finance on les a le problème c'est qu'on
n'arrive pas à recruter le médecin alors
il y a probablement il peut y avoir une
question de salaire je rappelle
simplement que entre 2021 et 2023 les
les médecins scolaires ont été
revalorisés autour de 7500 euros
alors juste sur le message mais après je
vais prendre ces infirmières sur les
médecins simplement pardon je suis un
peu le technicien d'étape mais mais pour
les médecins on est à 7500 euros de
revalorisation entre 2021 et 2023 7700
euros par an bon
la difficulté qu'on a c'est que très
concrètement quand on regarde la
cartographie de la médecine scolaire
nous avons pour les médecins scolaires
exactement les mêmes problèmes que nous
avons pour la médecine de ville et
d'ailleurs moi plusieurs fois dit mais
pourquoi ne faites-vous pas intervenir
des médecins de ville ne rétablissement
pour compenser simplement parce qu'en
général on vis-à-vis je n'en ai pas
et donc alors moi je suis tout à fait
prêt à concevoir qu'il y a une
difficulté propre de recrutement
médecine scolaire mais malheureusement
cette difficulté elle trouve un écho
très direct dans la démographie médicale
globale et à laquelle très honnêtement
pour l'instant on a du mal à trouver des
solutions sur les infirmières scolaires
donc on est à 7745 ETP qui sont prévus
donc en loi de finances on sature
quasiment le schéma d'emploi le plafond
d'emploi c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas on a eu un très
concrètement on a eu un artefact
poscovide donc l'année qui a suivi le
covid on a eu pour la première fois une
difficulté pour saturer les postes au
concours
ses revenus là à la à la norme donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de
difficultés pour entre guillemets
assurer le plein aux affirmières
elles ont été valorisées dans le cadre
du Ségur sauf erreur ça a été 957 euros
brut annuel auquel on a ajouté 580 euros
bruts annuel l'année dernière côté côté
éducation nationale
et on a recréé des postes d'ailleurs je
signale en 202 à la rentrée scolaire
2022 on a recréé 50 postes d'infirmières
supplémentaires c'est la première fois
depuis très longtemps qu'on recrée des
poses d'infirmières vous dire qu'il en
faudrait pas plus etc très probablement
il y a un effort à faire sur le sur la
médecine scolaire mais en tout cas c'est
pas un chiffre en baisse et on a même
recréé en 2022 sur les CPE de la même
façon on a recréé 300 postes à la
rentrée scolaire 2022 de conseiller
principaux éducation et là encore ça
fait partie de effectivement d'une
réponse globale
donc et sur les as de mémoire on a dû il
me semble qu'on a fait des poses d'as
donc on est stable une vingtaine de
poses d'as pardon je vérifie juste le
chiffre avec mon
je dis pas que tout va bien je dis juste
que
non non je n'ai excusez-moi monsieur le
député monsieur là je vous avais posé
des questions le DG SCO vous apporte des
réponses maintenant
non alors
il est Monsieur le Député il vous
apporte des réponses précises et
chiffrées maintenant qu'elle ne vous
conviennent pas
c'est une chose
maintenant monsieur le vous avez la
parole pour continuer à donner les
réponses mes chers collègues est-ce
qu'on peut s'écouter s'il vous plaît
bon monsieur le continuez je visiblement
les députés qui ont posé les questions
ne souhaitent pas entendre les réponses
mais les députés les autres dans la
salle oui donc
je ne prétends pas que la situation soit
bonne on est sur assistante scolaire sur
une situation critique en termes de
recrutement et qui est des efforts à
faire sur la société scolaire ça ne fait
absolument aucun doute juste que vous
avez compris d'ailleurs sur la dimension
de santé mentale etc des élèves
la chose que que je dis c'est que vous
m'avez posé la question de savoir si
aujourd'hui il y avait une baisse du
nombre de ces personnels la réponse est
non sont-ils un nombre suffisant le
débat il peut être la vocation est
traité en loi de finance par la
présentation nationale mais en revanche
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de baisse de
recrutement de ces de ces personnels en
revanche une difficulté à recruter mais
ça scolaire qui est une difficulté
objectivement absolument massive voilà
ça c'est
[Musique]
en plus du temps scolaire ça se passe en
dehors du temps scolaire dans les locaux
de l'école dans scolaires
il me semble à ce stade et en première
année assez évident que comme pour tout
usage des locaux scolaires ça se fait
avec l'accord de la commune donc je vais
regarder la situation précise que vous
avez ok parce que pour le coup le point
que je ne conteste pas mais le point
m'étonne dans la dans la procédure
administrative donc je vais le regarder
de près et je me permettrai de revenir
vers vous pour vous en tenir informés
sur les questions de relation entre les
parents
et les professeurs et sur l'ensemble en
fait des questions dans le fond autour
de réflexion parent professeurs
violences etc bon alors premièrement il
est évident que dans la prévention des
violences et du harcèlement
la si je puis dire la connexion avec les
parents la relation avec les parents
elle est centrale elle est centrale
parce que le propre de ces situations
c'est qu'elles sont sournoises
c'est qu'elles sont tues et en fait
qu'elles soient un tas de petits signaux
faibles et donc on a un enjeu de pour le
coup là de culture commune sur la
détection des signaux faibles qui doit
nous permettre collectivement de
d'interagir et de parler par un
professionnel que chacun puisse dire à
l'autre vous savez en ce moment j'ai
remarqué tel ou tel comportement est-ce
que c'est normal
ça c'est le premier élément
et ça ça suppose effectivement c'est à
dire une difficulté assez récurrente
mais ça suppose qu'on arrive aussi à
créer des espaces entre guillemets enfin
il faut que y compris
savoir une interaction
entre les parents et les professeurs moi
je j'ai rencontré beaucoup d'équipes
depuis plusieurs années qui notamment
ont toujours mis en évidence à de
manière assez récurrente que le
nécessaire renforcement de sécurité
poste attentat etc lié à la mise en
place de vigilirates un paradoxalement
réduit si je puis dire l'espace
d'interaction entre les parents et
l'école et donc parfois à conduit à ce
qu'on passe à côté de certains échanges
donc il y a très clairement là-dessus
quelque chose à faire il y a
effectivement quelque chose à faire du
côté aussi de la culture commune de la
relation aux écrans et réseaux sociaux
vous avez voté d'ailleurs la loi sur la
majorité numérique donc effectivement il
y a un enjeu majeur c'est comment faire
en sorte que des réseaux sociaux
s'assurent effectivement que enfin de
l'âge du mineur qui crée un compte et
que cet âge est conforme aux
dispositions légales et en même temps et
c'est là qu'on commence à être sur deux
pieds tout en minimisant aussi la
collecte de données
parce que pour le réseau social a donné
sur un mineur moi on est rassuré donc il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver cet
équilibre là donc il y a des travaux
effectivement qui qui je pense sont en
cours du côté notamment du ministre du
numérique mais il y a une réflexion
effectivement qui est le ministre
d'ailleurs de l'équipe nationale a vu la
semaine dernière les gens dans le
barreau les réseaux sociaux et donc on
sera amené évidemment à faire ministre
amener à revenir vers vous et à vous en
dire plus très prochainement sur les
questions d'orientation
alors c'est évidemment fondamental on
considère aujourd'hui dans les études
qu'on a qui sont ce qu'elles sont mais
on considère aujourd'hui qu'un élève de
fin de troisième il connaît entre 10 et
15 métiers
et qui sont généralement liés à son
environnement familial social immédiat
si on veut garantir la qualité des
chances il faut garantir que un élève
puisse avoir une ambition si je puis
dire égale quel que soit son
environnement familial social etc etc
d'origine et la découverte des métiers
elle sert à ça c'est que l'objectif
qu'on s'est fixé c'est qu'un élève en
sortant de 3e ils connaissent environ 50
métiers
à ce stade pour cette année qu'une année
donc de génération avec des métiers ça a
été donc expérimenté dans 560
établissements dans les 560 missions
volontaires au passage
je l'indique c'est intéressant
habituellement contre une
expérimentation
pour essayer un dispositif et voir
quelles sont les difficultés qu'on
rencontre on tourne autour de 150 170
établissements volontaires c'est
vraiment moi les tâches communs
quand on a proposé les établissements de
son secrétaire des métiers on a eu 500
volontaire donc ça veut quand même dire
que c'est un sujet si vous voulez qui
intéresse dans notre dans notre système
donc c'est 500 établissements montés ils
ont fait un stand de recommandation ils
ont rotation de difficulté donc cette
année en étant l'objectif c'est que il
se passe cette année pour cette
transition
quelque chose partout autour de trois
axes 1 la découverte de secteurs
d'activité pas forcément la découverte
d'un métier en particulier parce que
sinon ça va tourner à l'imagerie des
métiers ça va pas servir à grand chose
en revanche découvrez un secteur
d'activité et découvert que les 4 5 10
30 secteurs d'activité que j'ai exploré
entre la 5ème et la troisième il
présente des métiers communs et il
présente des métiers spécifiques ça
c'est intéressant
parce qu'on a aujourd'hui des enfants
qui quand ils se projettent sur un
métier se projeter sur un métier sur un
métier dans un secteur
et donc le premier horizon à ouvrir ça
veut dire mais en fait le métier auquel
tu aspires il t'ouvre 10 ou 15 secteurs
différents et ensuite le météoquel tu
aspires il s'insère dans un tissu de
métier qui pourrait aussi t'intéresser
et puis au passage tu peux aussi ouvrir
absolument pas pensé mais qui pourrait
être passionné donc ça c'est la première
dimension la deuxième dimension c'est la
dimension de rencontre avec des
professionnels soit qu'on les fasse
venir dans l'établissement soit qu'on
vous fasse visiter des
usines etc etc ou des ou des ou des
entreprises ou des administrations avec
des stages évidemment qui doivent être
pouvoir être faits à la clé
moi-même d'ailleurs comme j'accue chaque
année des stagiaires de troisième à la
digisco c'est toujours une découverte
pour eux que de voir ce à quoi ressemble
à des Giscos j'espère qu'ils aient la
vocation de l'indigesco c'est autre
chose mais au moins il voit ce que c'est
que la vie dans des escrocs
le troisième élément qui est important
aussi c'est et même très important c'est
la découverte des parcours postes 3e
aujourd'hui en fait qui se projette et
c'est normal et de famille qui se
projette sur le ressort territorial
immédiat et c'est une des difficultés
et avec des représentations du coup
associé à une expérience de vie qui fait
qu'on se sent tellement vers
l'industriel ou vers le tertiaire sans
savoir forcément toute la gamme qui a et
donc l'objectif c'est que désormais tous
les élèves quand ils arriveront en fin
de collège donc d'ici trois ans en terme
d'effet de cohort auront découvert
différents différentes voies
professionnelles évidemment la voie
générale différentes voies
technologiques différents droits
professionnels à la fois industriels et
tertiaires bien sûr et aussi
l'enseignement agricole
parce que là aussi on a des besoins qui
sont absolument considérables et en fait
si on vit dans l'ignorance de
l'enseignement d'école on peut pas
savoir sauf qu'elle particulier si on a
une vocation spécifique donc c'est
vraiment les trois axes qui seront mis
en oeuvre
sur
alors pardon parce que je me suis perçu
monsieur le député Mola que je n'avais
pas répondu tout à l'heure à votre
question donc je vous prie mon excusez
donc je reviens dessus du coup
sur la partie notamment
enseignant bilingue je alors d'abord les
exéates les iniacs exéades sont par
définition toujours possible mais il
faut aussi susciter des vocations et
donc vous savez qu'on ouvre un pppe donc
un parcours préparatoire pour professeur
des écoles cette année à Brest en
filière bilan précisément pour alimenter
la filière dans le premier degré et par
ailleurs au CAPES de Breton je crois
savoir qu'il y aura des postes qui
seront ouverts cette année
supplémentaire et il y aura également
externe de breton mais moi je crois
beaucoup aux dispositif pppe parce que
je pense qu'en fait on peut toujours
agir sur une place au concours à la fin
mais à la fin ça crée pas la vocation et
début en revanche si dès le départ on
accompagne ce type de parcours on peut
vraiment tenir des résultats qui sont
qui sont intéressants et donc on compte
là dessus sur les écarts de rémunération
est-ce que le pacte est un échec ou
est-ce qu'il n'a pas marché je dirais ni
l'un ni l'autre même si ça de façon de
dire la même chose parce que je ne suis
pas sûr de voir à ce stade en tout cas
le paysage est justement de la même
couleur mais ça ne vous surprendra pas
alors d'abord je n'ai pas aujourd'hui
donc comme je voulais dire de remonter
statistique universel et donc fiable sur
le pacte
en revanche on a quand même un stand de
retour empirique par des établissements
et qui montre que
on a on a je suis pas cap de convertir
ça en taux d'appropriation parce que
j'ai pas une photographie tous les
établissements ils perdent des
géographies diverses et variées mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas en mesure de vous dire
que le pack ne serait pas assez pris ou
ne serait pas pris et là où j'ai des
échos évidemment vous allez me dire j'ai
des échos de là où ça marche mais là où
j'ai des échos j'ai des échos qui sont
globalement plutôt positifs et notamment
ce qui fait lui avec une autre question
qui était posée juste après sur les
sessions de soutien d'approfondissement
puisque cessation de soutien
d'approfondissement effectivement
vocation aussi bien être assuré par des
professeurs des écoles que par des
professeurs du second degré et ça et
alors pardon parce que c'est pédagogique
mais c'est extrêmement intéressant en
fait ce qui se passe ça fait des années
que tout le monde parle de l'Inter degré
de la continuité inter degré de pourquoi
elle cette rupture entre le premier
évolution de grec etc etc c'est la
première fois qu'on crée un espace
pédagogique d'interaction entre les
professeurs du premier degré et les
professeurs de second degré directement
autour de l'élève certains les
professeurs qui vont parler ensemble du
niveau de leurs élèves qui vont
travailler ensemble des pratiques
pédagogiques pour les faire s'améliorer
dans la compétence et qui vont avoir les
mêmes élèves au même moment ça n'existe
pas ça les mêmes éléments entre le
premier degrés donc là on a des
professeurs qui vont avoir les mêmes
élèves pendant un an sur des sessions
évidemment sur des cours différents mais
qui vont à les mêmes élèves et qui vont
pouvoir travailler ensemble et en tout
cas dans les dans les dans les premières
indications purement empiriques que j'ai
de différents établissements tests qu'on
a parce qu'on a nos établissement test
évidemment conçu en particulier avec
lesquels on travaille pour savoir ce qui
marche c'est clairement aujourd'hui un
des éléments qui est en tout cas
apprécié on verra dans les enquêtes
contrastes si les plébiscités mais en
tout cas il est apprécié par les
professeurs des écoles
sur la réforme du lycée professionnel
vous avez demandé où on était de la
terminale donc alors là-dessus
simplement les travaux sont en cours et
constatations sont en cours donc voilà
il y a ce il y a cette idée de repenser
la terminale et notamment la fin de
l'année de terminale pour permettre aux
élèves de finalement cultiver
leur trajectoire selon qu'ils veulent
s'inscrire professionnellement ou selon
qu'ils veulent poursuivre des études
mais là dessus les travaux les travaux
sont en cours donc pour le coup tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que la
constatation fait son oeuvre sur la
question des de Lia générative alors qui
est encore une autre question
qui passe pas complètement simple parce
que
alors on a plusieurs choses bon d'abord
interdire pour interdire moi je rejoins
ce que vous dites député ça a pas
forcément beaucoup de sens les élèves
ils utiliseront ces outils en revanche
on a on a deux sujets un c'est
leur faire prendre conscience des
mécanismes réels sous-jacents de saisir
ce sujet génératif en fait
pour un centre notamment la plus célèbre
elles ne fonctionnent pas par une
connaissance qu'elles interrogent elle
fonctionne par des associations de mots
clés qui sont les plus fréquemment
repérés ensemble
c'est comme ça que vous sortir des
aberrations complètes historiques ou
autres d'ailleurs mais historique en
particulier donc faire comprendre ça un
élève
et tester notamment auprès d'adolescence
c'est déjà leur faire comprendre que lia
générative il peut évidemment utiliser
un cas elle a quand même ses limites le
deuxième élément c'est le
[Musique]
l'appréhension aussi par les professeurs
et la formation finalement des
professeurs aux bons usages donc là
dessus on est évidemment alors notre
opérateur de formation au numérique et
par le numérique c'est canopée qui
connaît une extension très très
régulière de son offre de formation
et donc il y a très clairement enfin
d'ailleurs canopée travaille dessus en
ce moment même avec l'élection du
exploitation mais il y a très clairement
des formations à mettre en place
formation qui malgré tout ne
compenseront pas totalement le
bouleversement enfin l'appréhension du
bouleversement technologique que ces
représentent moi je vois quand même que
la première clé objectivement c'est
d'abord
du côté de l'élève pour lui faire
comprendre enfin pour lui faire prendre
conscience des limites de ces de ces de
ces dispositifs
sur les
alors pardon j'essaie de répondre au fur
et à mesure sans personne sur les
concours alors il y a eu plusieurs
questions au concours les unes sur le
niveau de recrutement les autres sur le
nombre de postes ont pourvu les écarts
entre postaux pourvu aujourd'hui post-up
donc alors d'abord donc effectivement un
poste non pourvu au concours ne signifie
pas un poste non plus à la rentrée c'est
simplement dire que le rendement du
concours n'a pas été à 100% et donc au
terme des concours il reste 1000 1500
2000 places vacantes etc etc bon
ces places vacantes elles ont
effectivement vocation lorsqu'elles
demeure à être pourvu par des
contractuels
les contractuels étant soit
décontractuelles ayant déjà une
expérience de l'enseignement j'ai pas
photographié pour cette année l'année
dernière 90% des cours actuels en
exercice indication nationale au 1er
septembre 2022 avait déjà une expérience
d'enseignement précédente soit qu'ils
étaient conventuels les avant soit
qu'ils aient déjà été dans une vie
antérieure professeur qui est une
interruption qui soit revenu donc ça
c'est la première dimension et c'est ce
qui fait qu'effectivement aujourd'hui on
a un nombre assez faible de postes non
pourvu au sens j'allais dire pardon un
échange budgétaire du terme c'est à dire
impose tout vert en loi de finance un
professeur à mettre en face
les le niveau de recrutement alors
j'avoue que je suis pas j'ai pas les
chiffres en tête et donc là aussi déjà
je serai plus compétent que que moi sur
les concours le niveau de recrutement en
termes de notes au concours il est
effectivement très vapeur selon les
académie
il est historiquement plus faible dans
les académies les moins actives alors il
faudra d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle les
moins intactives parce que en vérité on
a des effets démographiques c'est-à-dire
que on recrute beaucoup plus sur la
secrétaire c'est évident tout simplement
parce que à eux deux c'est deux
académies là L2 elle est représente
quelque chose comme 15 ou 18% des élèves
de France
et j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup plus de
candidats sur ces académies donc c'est
pas que enfin il y a pas de
disproportion manifeste en revanche
effectivement le taux de candidats par
rapport au nombre de postes ouverts est
évidemment
moins intéressant moins attractifs que à
Bordeaux ou à Rennes ça c'est très clair
et donc c'est ce qui fait que
mécaniquement à Bordeaux à Rennes on a
un taux de sélectivité qui est plus
élevé et donc une moyenne c'est plus
élevée après la moyenne je suis je suis
un tout petit peu prudent sur son usage
parce que le principe d'un concours
c'est qu'il est fait en fait pour
sélectionner les gens dont on veut dire
qu'ils sont aptes et enfin je veux dire
si il suffirait demain de changer ta
main pour dire bah on prend tous les
gens qui ont plus de 10 il suffirait de
dire bah voilà et puis en fait on
prendra les mêmes ils auraient plus de
10 donc moi personnellement c'est pas
forcément ce que je fais enfin je suis
pas sûr que ce soit la clé des tueurs la
plus la plus immédiatement lisible
il y a deux choses bon un d'abord sur
les étudiants qui ont un master
Master 2 ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
de je crois 20% de la population
étudiantine donc française d'un âge
donné donc quand même des étudiants qui
ont tenu un Master 2
de son étudiants qui ensuite reçoit ont
été un Mastermind soit ensuite suivez
une formation adaptée
il y a très clairement et le ministre
d'ailleurs on l'a dit une réflexion sur
la formation initiale et sur le type de
formation qu'on est capable d'apporter à
ses élèves et sur la trajectoire de
professionnels progressive à apporter et
on va dire l'effort pour nous il a
plutôt vocation à être porté sur cette
dimension là et sur les conditions
d'activité globale de rémunération
d'accès au logement aussi parce qu'on
est de France c'est un autre problème
qu'on rencontre comme vous le savez
que sur que sur d'autres aspects vous
avez été plusieurs également à
mentionner les questions de défiance
vous êtes plusieurs on peut s'expression
de défiance des parents vis-à-vis de
l'institution
alors sur cette partie là
moi de ce que j'observe en tout cas dans
les différents sondages qu'on lit etc
c'est que c'est une situation qui est
assez commune aux différentes
institutions c'est à dire que
généralement le taux de confiance
augmente au fur et à mesure que la
question porte sur la proximité
immédiate de la personne autrement dit
vous voyez aux gens est-ce que vous
faites confiance à l'institution
générale
quel que soit ils vous disent
moyennement ou pas du tout
vous dites mais est-ce que vous faites
confiance à vos professeurs votre école
les vous répondre massivement oui donc
quand on était en gênant sur leur école
ou leur établissement ou leur professeur
il vous dit ils sont enfin en tout les
éléments que j'ai vu ces dernières
sondages est toujours extrêmement
négatif quand vous interrogez sur le
système en général ils sont beaucoup
plus inquiets mais un peu comme quand
vous leur demandez sur votre situation à
vous et sur votre situation du pays vous
avez toujours un décalage de perception
ce qui en revanche n'empêche pas que on
a un travail je rejoins je reprends du
coup à la question qui était posée sur
les départs du pays vers le privé on a
évidemment un travail à faire sur
mais comme toujours mais sur la qualité
du service public et sur l'attractivité
du service public de questions alors de
ce point de vue là nous n'observons pas
de départ du public vers le prix du
public c'est ça vers le privé au sens où
la part des lettres dans le privé et
strictement la même et c'est même
d'ailleurs l'inverse quand vous regardez
la note d'information de la dette
surtout si je suis là sont parfaitement
publics ils sont dans le dans ce petit
ouvrage qu'on appelle le dragon le Hertz
repère les références statistiques 2023
qui est en ligne et quasimatous donc
chaque année il y a les évolutions ligne
niveau par niveau etc etc
et l'adepte publie des notes
d'information qui éclaire telle ou tel
aspect la DPP a fait dernière une note
d'information sur donc le bilan de
rentrée donc elle a dû sortir je pense
au mois de mars sur la rentrée 2022
donc on en aura une à nouveau cette
année qui montre au contraire en fait
que la chute démographique a été plus
importante dans le privé dans le public
et notamment à l'entrée en 6e
je pourrais évidemment vous envoyer
d'informations mais c'est une note
d'information DEP constat de rentrer
effectivement de rentrer 2022 et vous
verrez il y a vraiment un tableau qui
explore à chaque niveau 6e 5e 3e etc et
on constate en fait
d'ailleurs pour la première fois parce
que historiquement il y avait tendance à
avoir plutôt une surpondération
démographique dans le privé et bien là
en fait la baisse démographique a été
plus importante dans le privé que dans
le public à la rentrée dernière et
globalement en tout cas j'allais dire
sur longue période le pourcentage au
dixième près il est absolument identique
entre la part des actions privées et la
part qui sont en public donc ça veut pas
dire que ponctuellement il n'y a pas des
comportements des choix de famille
des vêtements de fuite dans un sens dans
un autre mais au niveau global en tout
cas il n'y a pas d'aujourd'hui de
mouvement inquiétant et c'est même
plutôt l'inverse si on prend les
constats de rentrée 2022
il n'empêche que et
ment dit le ministre y compris dans le
ministère il faut renforcer
l'attractivité des établissements
publics c'est l'un des enjeux du
remplacement de courte durée
et donc de sa mise en oeuvre dans le
cadre notamment du pacte d'enseignant
c'est aussi l'un des enjeux des filières
attractives je rappelle simplement un
chiffre important nous avons
créé
60% de sections internationales en plus
en deux ans
on est passé de 85 après de 150
et l'intégralité de ces sessions
internationales nouvelles ont été
ouvertes dans les collèges qui font
partie des trois des cils les moins
favorisés
avec un effet immédiat c'est que l'IPS a
augmenté de 8 à 30 points dans ces
établissements
parce que les gens sont restés au lieu
de partir etc etc et parce que l'image
d'établissements a changé et ça les
chiffres on les a aussi c'est chiffre de
la dette on a des sud très très précises
quand on ouvre une section
internationale je pense les emplois et
c'était celui sur qui il y avait des
distorsions entre les établissements les
plus favorisés les moins favorisés sur
les autres domaines honnêtement on est
sur la répartition à peu près équanimes
mais sur celle-ci il y avait vraiment
une brillance rétablissement et moins
favorisée et donc on a ouvert ces
dernières années 43 puis 16 en 2 ans
section internationale les faits sur
l'IPS il est immédiat
sur
les SEGPA alors d'abord je me permets
pardon mais de vous remercier d'avoir
salué le travail des professeurs de
SEGPA et
dans les limites de mon devoir de
réserve de fonctionnaires je m'en fiche
que comme vous
profondément vraiment profondément je
suis très heurté des gens qui pensent
qu'on peut se moquer des SEGPA
ou sur les payer entre guillemets
dans quelle concerne que ce soit et y
compris dans des enceintes publiques je
trouve quelque chose de très de très
chaud nous insecte pas ils sont enfin
quand on est allé en sait qu'ils sont
merveilleux et leurs professeurs ils
sont exceptionnels
donc voilà j'en profite pour le dire
parce que parce que je le crois alors
les
à ma connaissance en tout cas on a on a
on vient de regarder du coup dans le
repère et statistiques de référence
les effectifs de cette pas et les moyens
qui leur sont attribués n'ont pas baissé
ça c'est clair
on est sur une stabilité donc là dessus
a priori il y a pas de difficulté
enfin pas de difficulté sens pas de pas
de signal d'alerte en revanche il y a un
point que vous allez souligner et qui me
préoccupe beaucoup en lien avec le
premier élément de ma réponse qui nous
préoccupe tous c'est la question
évidemment des sujets de harcèlement ou
de moquerie ou de discrimination entre
guillemets peuvent faire l'objet
et alors de ce point de vue là je
rejoins ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur le CNR parce que c'est très
intéressant
on va pas te décréter depuis la rue de
Grenelle qu'il faut désormais que tous
les segpates travaillent comme si vous
avez comme ça avec les autres élèves ça
aurait aucun sens en revanche ce que
j'observé dans les projets CNR c'est
qu'on a beaucoup de projets CNR qui
travaillent sur une meilleure
intégration des SEGPA au reste de
l'établissement et c'est là qu'on
retrouve l'intérêt de la souplesse
locale
mes équipements c'est pas dire ce qui
est bon d'office dans un établissement
en revanche quand une équipe locale et
ben non on est prêt à faire des projets
on a besoin de 5000 euros d'un peu de
formation d'un peu de temps d'un espace
pour accueillir les parents etc etc et
ben oui on le finance et on a des
projets qui sont vraiment très
intéressants là-dessus et si vous voulez
d'ailleurs enfin moi je serais vos
dispositions pour pour revenir vers vous
sur ce sujet là
la révision des questions du calendrier
du calendrier des questions prioritaires
pardon donc sur ce point donc vous savez
que c'est effectivement un sujet qui est
extraordinairement complexe
et surtout qui a vocation à être autant
que possible articulée avec d'autres
réflexions notamment sur le quartier de
politique de la ville
en pratique la cartographie la politique
de la ville elle est annoncée en
révision pour le 1er septembre 2025
et donc notre idée c'est histoire de pas
avoir deux exercices qui soient
complètement incohérents en partant de
non aligné enfin nous on articulé en
partant de données qui sont quand même
comparables etc c'est de faire concorder
les deux exercices donc on serait a
priori sur une réflexion en vue de la
rentrée 2025 ce qui n'empêche pas de
location pour essayer de loin de se
mettre en place puis vous savez qu'on a
les contrats locaux d'accompagnement qui
permettent d'organiser transition et
notamment dans certains territoires
objectivement les éléments concordent
pour dire qu'ils devraient être
classification ou indication prioritaire
renforcée on met en place ces
dispositifs
il y avait une dernière question je
crois sur deux dernières questions sur
le SMU et sur l'éducation asexualité
donc choisi la sexualité le Conseil par
des programmes effectivement été saisis
d'un travail si vous savez qu'il n'y a
pas de programme l'éducation asexualité
donc l'idée c'est que le concept pas des
programmes a été saisi pour construire
un référentiel dans ce domaine qui
serait commun à tous et qui au passage
d'ailleurs permettrait aussi de de
battre en brèche certaines
instrumentalisations ne serait-ce que
l’expression et qui font se nourrir tout
un tas de choses qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être quand on regarde concrètement ce
que sont les actions des questions et
sexualité donc ça le Conseil des profs
est actuellement en cours au travail
dessus et donc pour un effet à la
rentrée 24 et puis sur la génération du
SMU alors là j'avoue que évidemment le
mieux zen de vous répondre s'il a dégagé
général oui c'est lui qui serait
évidemment mieux armé ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'on est actuellement
donc dans le dispositif de d'appels mais
sur l'intérêt pour les classer lycées
engagés on a ce travail de de
recensement qui qui se fait enfin
d'adhésion qui se fait qui évidemment
travaille important
l'idée étant que progressivement
effectivement une partie séjour de
cohésion puisse avoir lieu dans le
courant de l'année scolaire alors ce qui
est très lié bien sûr aux enjeux de
reconquête du mois de juin puisque
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on a mois de juin
qui est quand même dans un temple de cas
est quand même raccourci notamment pour
les élèves de seconde et donc
dans le cas on va dire
d'un reformatage global et scolaire en
fait le séjour de cohésion peut tout à
fait trouver sa place dans cette
perspective là donc c'est sûr sur quoi
on est en train de travailler
actuellement mais pour l'instant et avec
le doigt de connaissance qui est le mien
qui est forcément plus faible sur le
Scénic sur d'autres on est surtout en
face donc de de mise en place de cet
appel à manifestation d'intérêt
merci Monsieur le Directeur je crois que
vous avez répondu en effet à toutes les
questions maintenant il me semble à
moins que un collègue non c'est bon je
ne vois pas donc merci beaucoup pour vos
réponses claire précise et chiffrées qui
même si certains ont pu contester dans
son pas moins exact les documents vous
le sont à disposition des uns et des
autres et je rappelle à mes collègues
que nous nous retrouvons à 15h en salle
Lamartine pour une table ronde
réunissant les représentants syndicaux à
tout à l'heure
merci au revoir